man this whole week it was just
dominated with talk about Crowder and
the daily wire I'm I'm glad that for
this Friday at least we can get back to
our regularly scheduled Civil War talk
you know we're talking about Civil War
instead of talking about drama between
big media companies you know what I mean
Tim cast classic uh over in the Atlanta
area a bunch of far left extremists have
been occupying the space because they
don't want police to set up a training
center
the police tried to come in to clear it
out because these people have been
firebombing buildings fire bombed and
innocent guys truck nearly burned him to
death we're throwing rocks through
Windows throwing mouths off cocktails
the cops move in one of these foreign
extremists shoots a cop severely
injuring him police returned fire and
self-defense killing the antifa guy in
retaliation antifa is now calling for
the assassination of police in the area
putting the city on high alert holy crap
I didn't see that one coming but this uh
this autonomous Zone has been going on
for some time so we'll talk about that
plus a bunch of other news we got this
crazy new email from the hunter Biden
laptop Joe Biden was directly working
with Hunter according to his email on a
on selling energy to China which calls
into question a whole lot obviously dude
was was lying Biden's been lying with
everything but now I'm wondering about
the strategy of getting natural gas into
Europe if the bidens have been doing
these Shady deals to China who is our
principal adversary so we'll talk about
that plus I'm really excited it's Friday
we're gonna talk about Velma because uh
it's the third lowest rated show in
history and it's just under garbage so
we'll get some culture War stuff and
then uh the economic forum is wrapping
up so we'll talk about all that and uh
we'll get into it should be fun before
we get started head over to timcast.com
become a member click that join us
button to support our work as a member
you'll get access to our members only
uncensored show Monday through Thursday
at 11 PM Plus your membership supports
our cultural efforts and Endeavors we
have um I Heard the deck over here the
Tim Cascade company we're reclaiming
abandoned logos I'm wishing to go nuts
on this one these companies get attacked
by the woke they drop their logos they
drop their mascots because they're
offensive or whatever okay if they
abandon it I'll pick them up we'll make
Aunt Jemima's skateboards next we'll
just you know whatever whatever it takes
we're gonna do stuff like that but more
importantly we're setting up physical
locations where people can hang out we
want to create spaces we want to create
events where we can actually start
building out culture and pushing back if
you want to support us go to timcast.com
become a member smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the share
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is Jay
Dyer thank you glad to be here who are
you books uh I'm a nerd of the highest
class highest order uh Chad nerd
something here yeah that's good I do
geopolitics I do philosophy teach
courses you can get my course right now
on my YouTube channel the links are all
there but
um I host the fourth hour of Lord
Voldemort uh every Friday and we do
debates debated some of the top people
out there
Alex Jones
but literally you do the fourth hour of
Alex's show Alex Jones Show Friday quite
literally and I brought the documents
folks unbelievable I have all of the
documents here in front of me truly
literally have we seen an image of that
I don't think people could see the books
in the image can you pull them up you
got some good ones you got Klaus Schwab
you got the luxury in there you got some
good stuff in here you got to pull them
up a little bit I got the greatest oh
yeah there you go Greatest Hits that's
one set there's a second set too it's
the notes that make me most excited yeah
everybody laughs about these uh sticky
notes and they're like What's the
there's no Rhyme or Reason they're just
freaking sticky notes man H.G Wells
there that's a good one so that way when
someone says there's no way Klaus Schwab
said that then you go actually Lane you
can pull up the book and be like it's
right there there's a sticky notes so
clearly he said it that's right that
proves it that's right well it should be
fun man uh glad to have you absolutely
thank you yeah there's no way David
Rockefeller called for an end of
American sovereignty oh wait he did
actually walked up with him on his own
book actually and I also had one of
those sticky notes in there so I'm
excited to get into all that my name is
lucridowski here if we are change.org
and during these very trying very
difficult times I think we need a hero
that we all deserve right now and for me
that of course is ligma Johnson Lakewood
Johnson is a candidate endorsed by Elon
Musk and I think he's going to be uh the
candidate that will help solve all of
our problems in the next political
election I think if we all just focus on
ligma Johnson the world would be just a
way better place and uh you could too
endorse ligma Johnson on the best
politicalshirts.com because you do
that's why I'm here political Juggernaut
Olivia Johnson a force to be reckoned
with right uh you also mentioned you're
big into philosophy I think you said you
did you study you studied in college I
did and got ran out of there because I
wasn't uh woke enough well maybe we'll
talk about the philosophy of
transhumanism at some point definitely a
little bit in the show and it always
comes up when we talk about world
economic forum and you keep going deeper
and deeper you eventually get to people
that want to live forever or at least
extend their lifespan they will man it's
nuts even Lex Freeman tweeted out today
sometimes things are so good and it's so
sad to let go of them and see them end
and it's like just I see why I should
wear transhumanists why they are the way
they are because why when life is good
and you're rich why would you ever want
it to end I you know I get it well
search hi hey what's up Ian I am at
surf.com uh this will be a fun one uh I
hope uh you guys are having a good
Friday let's have a good one let's jump
into the store we got this from the post
millennial police on high alert
following death threats from Atlanta
Forest Defenders I just wanna I just
want to pause right there and say um I'm
gonna text Libby can I text Libby she's
the internet Chief um what's with this
headline I was gonna say that's my mom's
name texting my mom dude Forest
Defenders what do you mean you mean
domestic terrorists you mean the city of
Atlanta's on high alert after antifa
domestic terrorists opened fire on
police and then called for
assassinations come on post-millennial
you guys can do better than this here's
the story
seven it's from Andy no post millennial
seven charged with domestic terrorism
following deadly shooting at Atlanta
autonomous Zone
these people firebombed buildings
people are not from the Atlanta area
they were arrested and turns out they're
from all over the place so these random
psychopaths are coming down to Atlanta
feigning some kind of outrage over a
police training center
fire bombing people's firebombing houses
under construction not people living
there
a dude in a truck is driving up they
fire bomb his truck random innocent guy
he gets out and flees they destroyed his
truck flip it over
police job to stop him the guy shoots a
cop severely injuring him
the police returned fire and
self-defense antifa responds by issuing
a direct call for the assassination of
police in the area putting the city on
high alert hey I didn't I didn't have
that one on my 2023 bingo card but it
probably should have been right
um yeah who I'm not even hearing about
this in the news I mean I didn't know
that there was another autonomous it's
been there for like a year and a half
yeah which which is absolutely crazy
because the last time we kind of saw
this it was in Portland and it was
widely talked about and people were
trying to film in there but there's
there's nothing about any of this that
I've been actually hearing about myself
but to be fair I mean we were really
wrapped up talking about Stephen Crowder
yesterday I mean we couldn't we couldn't
spare any time I talk about antifa
terrorists getting arrested and trying
to kill police so is this a situation
where they're like this is our land and
then the cop stepped on their land and
they're like don't you're invading our
territory Bang Bang the cops were going
to use the facility as a training
facility right they want to build a
training center exactly and so a bunch
of
Psychopaths from all over the country
show up pretending they're angry that
Atlanta's doing this and then living in
trees and trying to kill people yeah
underground repeat stuff you remember
the story yeah but I don't think the
Weather Underground ever like almost
killed a cop didn't they bombed yeah
they did yeah but but my understanding
is that they were doing shock and awe
that they were intentionally trying to
avoid killing people but they were
trying to destroy stuff yeah so I could
be wrong I don't know I'm not an expert
on that so one when I'm so from what I'm
seeing online it looks like there was a
multi-agency operation that got rid of
25 campsites that were on this
autonomous Zone and they were able to
find a lot of weapons a lot of different
fireworks uh pellet rifles gas masks
boat uh boat torches uh but uh it looks
like there was a scuffle when of course
they were being kicked out of this
location I'm I'm I thought I heard a
story about The Weather Underground
having killed the cop or something but I
think when I do a Google search like I
think the only thing I find is they kill
themselves they were working on a bomb
in a basement it blew up and killed them
because my understanding is that a lot
of people talk about the weather
underground and you know compare it to
what's going on today with antifa and
then I often hear from you know people
who are more experts than I that yeah
but they were doing shock and awe
campaigns they would go two in the
morning when no one was around and blow
something up to be like aha look at us
whereas antifa literally just kills
people like the dude in Portland they
walked up and just shot him in the chest
that BLM guy and then you have all the
people who died I'll call this one
indirect far left you know death the
riots the summer of love but this is
like an escalation this is they shot a
cop put them in the hospital yeah we're
in an age now where you can radical well
you can rally much quicker with like
social media groups like Facebook groups
so there's a lot more
um instances of people identifying with
group names now like there's a lot of
different types of antifa groups that
are they probably don't even know each
other they're just saying yeah I'll do
that too I'll put a label on my shirt
and so there's going to be more likely
you're going to see like random acts of
violence and things I think the Weather
Underground is a much more focused group
that started apparent only in the campus
of the University of Michigan 1969 and
they probably knew each other pretty
well I don't know how it was Bill Ayers
who was a high level Foundation guy who
was basically funding and promoting all
that so that was actually an
establishment created thing which I
think antifa is as well so that's why I
was making the Weather Underground
connection and
um I think it's the same thing with uh
they gave a six minute warning before
bombing the New York Police Headquarters
The Weather Underground yeah
okay have you seen that interview where
they say though the they're interviewing
the weather on around people they're
like well we want to put half of America
into camps
what yeah Alex plays that clip all the
time it's just it's that they had the
attitude that half of America would have
to be re-educated so they were the first
to call for re-education camps yeah
Andrew Cuomo a very popular uh Governor
from uh New York former Governor
actually commuted a sentence for an ex
whether Underground member recently as
well which he was personally um you know
intervened and defended his decision in
doing so there's a vintage debate
between Lord Voldemort and Bill Ayers
it's pretty interesting I don't know if
anybody could ever dig that up but they
go into that and Alex actually brings
all that up
what was the topic of the debate what
were they discussing well Ayers was
trying to argue that he was actually
working for real liberalism and real
liberal causes and I think he was making
points that Tim was trying to make that
that they weren't really wanting to
supposedly hurt people but that it was a
real liberal movement knox's argument
that it wasn't so that it was Foundation
funded like a push oh interesting yeah
so Ayers was like working at high level
foundation so as a liberal you know what
the fact I don't remember if it was a
Ford Foundation something like that he
had some connection to a high level I
don't remember which one it was and then
so they played it off as if they were
anti-vietnam or something anti-war
anti-establishment what was the real
goal empowering the state
uh that depends on how legitimate I
guess the Weather Underground themselves
were I mean if whether they were
completely fed created thing or whether
it was
um a kind of a steered into radicalism
uh you know a lot of the cointelpro was
designed to do that steer people into
appearing radical it was a Richard Aoki
was the guy who steered the Panthers
into being radical and that basically
defused all of their PR right because
they were they were seen walking around
carrying guns and America thought oh the
Black Panthers are going to take over
America so it was this psyop and that's
exactly why I tell people the violence
doesn't work it's what the government
wants exactly when you get when you get
violent or scary the government can then
take that use it against you and justify
expansion because regular people say yes
please government don't do this when
antifa goes out and do it the media
covers it up never talks about it so no
one knows it's happening but you would
think if the media did talk about it
that would be
um a reason to fund the FBI to
investigate with us so what the heck's
going on because antifa is doing things
that they want I suppose I don't know I
mean look look at the Gretchen Whitmer
thing it's like 14 FBI agents and like
two dudes and they try and lock them up
they want the narrative to be the far
rights dangerous they don't want the
narrow to be the far left as dangerous
because they want to stop Trump things
like that
presumably my guess
so they could keep an antifa in their
back pocket as a militant arm of of the
liberal an economic order in case I
don't know things don't go the way that
the business is moving it I think
there's far right and far left that are
kind of managed like they serve a
purpose both of these groups and you'll
notice the history of you know
cointelpro there's usually Federal
informants in all of these whether it's
radical Islam groups look up the Newberg
sting documentary it's a classic there's
people like Ray Epps we still haven't
gotten answers about there you go what's
he on about you know what's the name my
favorite news story was a couple years
ago of uh the ATF busting down an FBI
ring because they were both undercover
and hearing stories like that uh you
know it just just gives me a little bit
of hope you ever hear that story of the
dude who set he created a fake grow
house he rented a house and then he put
grow lights in it Barry Cooper is that
is that I believe so and then so what
happened was
he knew that the DEA and the police were
doing illegal raids without warrants on
grow houses so he rents a house and he
puts very powerful grow lights in it and
nothing else but live streaming cameras
then of course one day they storm into
the house they break in without a
warrant and there's live streaming
cameras everywhere and there's like a
sign saying you're on camera or
something like that yeah I believe this
was Barry Cooper he was previously one
of the top best narcotics officers in
this entire country he got multiple
prestigious Awards by many federal
agencies and then he just realized that
the War on Drugs was absolutely stupid
and he dedicated his life towards
exposing how much of of of of a con this
was and then started to do tutorial
videos about how to get away with drug
dealing and and literally made tutorial
videos saying okay drug sniffing dogs do
this make sure you do this to not get
caught so uh that's another uh we uh
interesting individual that I met
previously before we put up a poll in
the chat right now who is Right Crowder
daily wire just to get your guys's
thoughts on the whole thing happened
this week Luke put up a poll I like my
poll what does your poll say well my
poll says uh let me just pull it up here
to see who's actually the winner here
but we need a third option here you
always need a third option I think your
option is like Democrat or Republicans
but
um surprisingly it's tied my poll is who
is in the right I have Crowder option
one daily wire option two and both are
status and both are wrong option three
uh is tied with daily wire oh at 36
right now it's tied oh yeah so votes
happening on my Twitter look we are
changing if you want to get involved in
that I personally voted for the third
option but that's just me uh but you
know let let the people speak let the
let the people vote both our statists
and wrong how's it going I couldn't vote
because I I just didn't I don't believe
any of them are wrong I usually don't
believe in voting but yeah I shouldn't I
should have on Twitter I put abstain and
most people said Epstein like I don't
want to be involved Jeffrey Epstein
yeah so I don't know man what do you
guys think huh is 2023 going to be the
year where it kicks off and gets you
know hot conflict are we going to see
the Resurgence of the crazy antifa stuff
we saw a couple years ago or is this
anomaly there's also another crazy story
just a couple days ago of of of a guy
who lost a local election and then went
up and shot up and shot up the home
offices of uh the the Democrats the
Democrats so you know that's another you
know story that I I think uh can you
believe should be talked about our first
swatting was one year ago this month oh
happy anniversary yeah it was the sixth
it was January 6th our first one
congrats yeah 15 15 times since then if
we sit by and just complain it will see
more violence and probably the the
dissolution of the United States but if
we actively create technology and
structures and communities that are
resilient to this kind of thing I think
we'll easily be able to bypass this and
remain a global leader so so I think
personally that there is a larger divide
and conquer agenda meant for for the
American people to tear each other up
beat each other up and find each other
as each other's enemies meanwhile the
real kind of culprits the real kind of
people behind the scenes that are
hurting both people are getting away
with a lot of their crimes against
humanity and seeing the the point that
we are at right now where a lot of
people are even afraid to have civil
conversations at the dinner table with
each other's family members seeing at
the situation where we are so polarized
we are so divided the ingredients that
created to that situation the social
media algorithms the divisive emotional
hyperbolic psyops the the news coverage
that that again is used to manipulate
people all those ingredients haven't
gone away you add that to the larger
ingredients of of people getting sicker
getting more unhealthier not just
physically but also mentally you add
that to Poverty increasing uh we're
we're we have a recipe for disaster with
all these ingredients kind of coming
here together and I think it's it's only
going to get way worse from here which
is absolutely horrible and something
that should be prevented and we should
have a real conversation about but sadly
we don't have that conversation and
sadly these ingredients are just being
being added to this larger mess of a
situation that we're all in when you say
only getting worse like what do you mean
exactly because I know things will get
better as well but what do you mean so
as far as like mental health right
mental health has been declining
dramatically in this country that's
going to have a severe effect on whether
people act violently you look at the
destruction of the family unit when you
look at the radicalization that happens
uh not just in the Middle East but but
with any kind of form of radicalism one
of the key components is not only low
intelligence but it's also low income
not a lot of abilities and not banging
at all not having the opportunity to
find a a female or male spouse they
attribute to this specifically in the
Middle East because there's a lot of men
that have multiple lives meaning that
there's a lot of guys who can't have a
wife meaning that they're more likely to
be radicalized now with the destruction
of the family unit people becoming
poorer people becoming more crazier
there's going to be more violence in the
United States whether we like it or not
because they they promise them 72
virgins in heaven
this is a story uh it's a crazy story I
was reading about uh hashash the
hashashin I think it was called it's
like the origination of the Assassins
yeah basically this dude would drug
young men and then drag their bodies to
a like a poppy field with a bunch of
like beautiful women dancing around and
then they'd wake up and he'd be like
this is Paradise look at all these women
they're all yours and they'd be like oh
how do I what is this like oh but you
can only get it if you serve and do what
you're told and he's like oh and then
they drug him again drag them back to
where they were before and then they
wake up and like what was that vision
and he's like if you do everything I say
you will go back there and so the
Assassins people don't understand
they they it's like we have this vision
of Assassins as you know ninjas wearing
all black crawling in through the
ceiling taking out the emperor and then
like throwing a rope and scurrying away
and that's not at all the assassins the
true assassins would dress like a
pre-store farmer walk in stab the crap
out of the leader and then be killed on
the spot by the leader supporters they
were they were like ah now I can go to
paradise or whatever so suicide bombers
of the day exactly yep yeah there were
people being poor not getting laid and
then having more mental health problems
and a lot of sand that is yeah yeah no
jokes and in places where you know yeah
that's why the fasting I think from
Ramadan is so important because it would
keep this super the hot heat you can't
you can't discount the hot heat of the
Middle East the hottest part yeah hot
heat
um it's not bad by the way great band
yeah
basically what led to Nazi Germany it
was the was the extreme degradation
poverty it wasn't the same surprising it
wasn't the heat um but it was like
environments where people didn't have no
money there yeah World War One created
that situation where of course they were
made to sign a treaty that essentially
robbed them of a lot of their wealth and
no you make you make a great Point
there's a there's a a some study or
something I remember hearing about this
during the Arab Spring three components
that led to the revolutions and it was
like the high cost of food the uh
inability to work and like a lack of
shelter or something like this like I
can't remember what the exact components
were but when when you have high levels
of homelessness unemployment and
inflation
for obvious reasons everything falls
apart I mean yeah or people become like
vulnerable to a strong personality
coming along and saying I can help you
that's the problem whether it's a person
or thing we will destroy that thing and
then you'll be okay and people are like
I'm so desperate
anything is better than starvation my
question for Jay is everything we're
seeing manufactured
uh not in US I mean in a in a sense uh I
think you have all these books in front
of you talking about the global Elites
and all that we hear from them all the
time about how they want less people uh
that lower population growth they want
more control and then I look at all the
stuff like why doesn't the media cover
antifa why do they run cover for antifa
and it's almost like they're serving
some kind of purpose yeah well I mean
the mass media is a creation of the same
people that set up the Davos the setup
Bilderberg to set up all the things that
we know of as the control structure
right now so the United Nations is a
creation of this same group and so if
you look at the history of the the
networks CBS NBC those were all run by
people who came out of wartime OSS
intelligence and they just took all of
that information that they learned from
wartime and applied it to mass media so
mass media has basically been that for
this entire time I was just watching
some old Walter Cronkite award reception
ceremonies and he was getting awards for
Global governance back in the 80s and he
was like a you know hardcore Global uh
promoter
um and he was a big promoter of
depopulation as well and so that's
definitely one of the themes I did a
talk the Ten Commandments of the global
Elite and that's one of those key key
Commandments is you have to maintain you
know population down at least under a
billion that's the near-term goal so and
the OSS was a predator accessor to the
CIA a lot of people need to realize that
as well what are the other tenants you
said there are 10 tenets of globalism
yeah I just basically went through a lot
of these texts and just kind of figured
it out what were the commonalities and
just kind of came up with my own 10 but
I mean it's you know it's a world
economic system based around you know
some form of universal basic income it's
a world religion uh I mean they all
write about that by twelkism the first
thing the first thing you mentioned uh
the Central Bank digital currency than
the local religion and also the the
Turning of the actual existing
establishment religions into something
that is a form of wokism yeah like the
Vatican this kind of stuff in my view
um you know they just push the vaticans
pushing World economic foreign
principles and inclusive capitalism
which is you know to Klaus has another
book inclusive capitalism so
um it's about the pendant hunting is a
cabinets
um that's not one of the Ten
Commandments penetration penetration key
component
um you know the the the creation of a
single government uh the creation of uh
a technocratic uh Central order I mean
the Kissinger France Jacques out to Lee
I brought his book um I mean his whole
book is about transhumanism basically
being the spirit the tip of the spear
for uh the New World Order he calls it
that like he says the whole chapter on
this is like the tip of the sphere is
transhumanism so that's another one of
these tenets how would transhumanism
function as a tip of the spear I mean
the first way I think of it is that they
can read your thoughts with the neural
net and then they can control your
behavior through that the other idea
would be that they make people so
depressed that they are become
vulnerable to manipulation let me give a
quick shout out to Stargate sg1
on an episode that I've talked about
before
those unfamiliar the show's Amazing by
the way it's a a team travels through a
Stargate portal to various coordinates
to explore other colonies essentially
like other planets and you know it's
complicated but basically they go to one
place where they they send out a drone
little robot and everything's destroyed
but then all of a sudden it flashes and
everything's fine there's a barrier over
this small town where everything outside
of it is polluted and this force field
is keeping everybody safe
they go inside they meet people
eventually they're like Hey where's that
guy we met and they go what guy and
they're like the guy John we met John
and they were like there's no one here
by that name and they're like what
randomly one person just leaves the city
and walks out to their death
what was happening was everyone had a
neural implant the Central Computer was
controlling their memories and when the
force field was shrinking as it ran out
of power it would excise people by
altering their brains to make them walk
to their death and then make everyone
forget they existed
that could be happening right now and
you wouldn't know it memory holding yeah
we could like fro there's another seat
right here guys look at this there's a
chair it's got it it's empty
there's another the camera's not on the
camera's not on ozone uh for all we know
there was a lost fifth
person
is that really is that part of the plan
uh how deep have you have you peered
pretty pretty is what part of like
having a controllable memory yeah
controlling people's minds I mean uh
interesting that's totally real I mean
you know there's a history of DARPA
attacks that Annie Jacobson wrote uh
it's a really good book um and she well
I think she got nominated from Pulitzer
she didn't win it but she did the other
famous book on Area 51 but in her
history of DARPA she talks about how the
there's actually collusion between
Hollywood and DARPA to have symbiotic
relationship between
the creators of TV shows taking ideas
like you're talking about Stargate and
then they have a reciprocal relationship
with DARPA where they get fed ideas and
they feed ideas to people at DARPA so
there's a whole chapter in that too
about MKUltra I don't know if you guys
know about that oh yeah I know I know
yeah you would know about that well the
CIA has been involved in Hollywood in so
many different ways especially when it
comes to planting and seating ideas
there's a reason that they promote
certain movies but they do more than
that I mean the dod gets involved in in
a lot of movies especially when it comes
to a lot of military movies a lot of War
propaganda but specifically the larger
psyops the larger implanting of
subconscious ideas is also done by a lot
of these Central controllers but a lot
of people even knowing it I saw that I
thought of a funny idea real quick
before we show your book I'm just like
this Shadow for Sheamus because of good
Freedom Tunes where it's like FBI agents
are watching Luke's content they get
assigned to watch Luke and they're like
you need to watch this guy and watch out
for his radicalization and radicalism
and the guys like yes sir you got it and
then it's like six months later and the
guy's sitting there wearing a tinfoil
hat like it's real it's real and they're
like ah Luke got another one and they
drag him off and but yeah you got a book
that's my goal how many how many FBI
agents have you have you radicalized
do you radicalized I hope I hope as many
as I can I'm doing my best
yeah so this one is you may have heard
of John C Lilly right he's the dolphin
dude uh he's this was part of MK Ultra
uh he he was doing a lot of experiments
with dolphins he actually had a thing
for dolphins is that the guy who was
whacking the dolphin off oh that's how
that's him that's the dog why was he
doing that hey paid for her by your tax
dollars right you guys you guys paid a
dude to crank it up and he was an early
uh like theorist when it came to how if
you saw the human being as a computer
you could program the human being just
like just lift it up a little more so
people can see the whole title oh the
book I think you're saying lift up my
spirit
well the way that they kind of like the
way that they Influence People now is
subconscious but but they're moving into
a new kind of way where we are going to
have some kind of implantable chip
inside of us today at the world economic
Forum a Duke Professor uh Nita farhani
actually talked about how in the very
near future we're going to have sensors
in each ear in order to monitor your
brain waves all day every day so we
already have wearable technology now
we're going to have implantable
technology and if you thought the
subconscious psyop propaganda in the in
the Hollywood movies by the CAA it was
bad imagine what happens when they get
access to your brain waves and are able
to manipulate that and stimulate that
for what they want to encourage and what
they want to discourage this is next
level Ray kurzweil's book on the
singularity has a whole chapter on that
very thing where he says that they'll
they'll step in between the data that
comes in from the exterior to your mind
and they'll have a layer in there to
tell you what's coming in and it won't
be the actual exterior data that's
coming in from the external world it's
what they want to hear and he says it'll
be done eventually by not by nanotech
when he was doing this back in the 60s
he was doing the actual like RFID chip
right putting it in the monkey or
whatever but in this book it actually
talks about experimenting on humans and
these are the same I just want to make
one more Point here these are the same
intelligence agencies that are already
he's saying you can't listen to this you
can't hear this they are denying you
access to information on social media
curating the algorithms denying people
spanning people imagine what they're
going to do when they're inside of your
head but why was that guy
cranking off a dolphin
the hard questions because mad
scientists are freaks yeah yeah because
I remember reading about something like
that and then but is is he an evil guy
like is this book he's writing talking
about his intentions that are bad or is
he writing a warning about what they're
going to do and he just so happened to
be a creeper who cranked a dolphins no
he's the 100 part of it like he he's a
believer in it so I mean I think all the
M culture doctors were were Believers
well how come how come all these people
these Global Elites do weird weird stuff
you know what I mean because when you
get so much I mean one Theory I mean we
don't know exactly some people believe
there's a spiritual a component to this
some people believe that they're taken
over by demons another aspect is
psychologically speaking when you have
so much power when you have so much
money there's things that just don't
affect you at all so they keep looking
for new bizarre crazy things that
actually give them some kind of feeling
in this life since they're so numb by
how much they have already accomplished
in this world that's that's another
theory there's other theories
one of the theories is that people who
want to do really messed up things seek
power in order to immunize themselves
from the law and society as they seek to
do it so like I don't know what level of
power this guy had but certainly someone
who wants control who's got messed up
predictions about dolphins is going to
need to insulate themselves from the law
if they're gonna do weird crap like that
and then you got the o Epstein stuff
clearly these people want to get
positions of power so that it's very
difficult to go after I mean look Andrew
prince Andrew why isn't that guy getting
charged
I mean what's up with that you know
Maxwell Goes to Jail what about The
Client List these people seek power
because then they can get they can then
get away with it because you look at you
look at what happens to people who
aren't in the club like those two guys I
think where was it those two guys with
Atlanta or something where they were
trapped they adopt two gay guys adopted
kids and then started raping and
trafficking them for money those guys
got arrested and people are calling for
the death penalty for what they did but
then take a look at the Epstein stuff
and it's like where is The Client List
people who wanted who want to do messed
up crap like that seek power so they can
become you know if they were politicians
those two two guys they probably would
have gotten away with it
um that's another aspect that people
stand here and a lot of these people are
just sociopaths so that's the third
explanation so I have I have these kind
of two explanations one they're just
kind of sociopaths uh two they're just
kind of numb for having too much power
and then you know one is that they're
they're hijacked by demons
that explains it or all of all three
above right but there's also an element
like in Dr Quigley's traging hope where
he's chronicling the history of the
elite in the 20th century he's one of
them by the way he's writing an
apologetic and traging hope there's a
chapter where he talks about
how the elite raised their children and
there's a at least in the British
tradition he's talking about the Royal
Society that they have the tradition to
intentionally inculcate psychopathy and
so one of the reasons that they would
send them to Elite boarding schools was
to separate them from the matronly you
know raising this kind of has a natural
production of psychopathy there's also
inbreeding as well in some of the Royal
Society groups which also can produce
that and by the way the reason to answer
that previous question about the tip of
the spear that's because
um that's a reference to the ongoing
Revolution that Huxley wrote about so if
you read Huxley not just brand new world
but his other text he has an essay at
the beginning of brand new world where
he says that this is the culmination of
all the Revolutions of the last several
centuries and that culmination is in a
strictly tiered technocratic Society
where everybody's controlled and babies
are born in in test tubes so it's it's a
it's an actual plan of Revolution that
continues up into transhumanism I I
think about like uh people that have so
much money and power starting to take
the NPC metaphor literally and then they
look at people and they start to look at
them as biomechanical machines and how
do you manipulate and control the
machine right as a and then so you lose
it that's I I do like saying like hey
people are NPCs hahaha but the reality
is no we're all humans and uh we all
have human rights in my opinion and we
should support those but I see that
happening well it's treated like a
machine so how do we tweak the machine
yeah what do you think is the the
biggest fight that's happening right now
because we are going through as Klaus
Schwab says a fourth Industrial
Revolution but where do you think the
front line of the fight is is it is it
AI is it social media is it
um you know the subconscious propaganda
how do you see this fight unfolding and
where's the number one fight happening
now well I have religious views so I
think that ultimately there's a
spiritual component that you were
talking about I do think at least
certain sections of the elite there is a
demonic possession that occurs so I
would agree with that
um so that's kind of the big picture in
my view but then
um yeah I think that if we don't stop
the implementation of a complete Tech
control grid it's over yeah like I was
watching this video of uh journalists
trying to interview class Schwab at
Davos a few days ago did you guys see
that and this girl and he's like
ignoring her ignoring her like he
doesn't have time he doesn't have time
and so I I want a light class I want to
be like maybe he's got his own path to
World unification I don't necessarily
agree with but I still I don't think
he's I think he thinks he's doing good
so in this interview she's trying to
interview him he walks away he comes
back and he's like who are you this who
are you this what company and she's like
I'm independent and he's like oh yeah
Okay and like why are you a dick Klaus
like don't be a dick dude we
need that that's what you can say yeah
maybe he is maybe he's actually like a
nasty guy I want to like him you thought
these people were nice well he's got
Chris why do you want to like these
crazy
Charisma they just use it for evil like
okay that's a problem with Charisma is
it can be used very nefariously well I
brought this classic about technocratic
age and I think you know him
he talked about a lot of this stuff too
way before it was even as as relevant as
it is today he really uh being your
Brzezinski uh was one of one of the
biggest uh you know representatives of
the Rockefeller family he was a part of
the counts on Foreign Relations the
Bilderberg Group their trilateral
commission uh he was the presidential uh
uh advisor and truly was also The
Mastermind behind the Mula hajin and the
Taliban uh in Afghanistan as well it was
uh he was the first person that I
confronted and had to run away from uh
security
after doing so on YouTube right yeah and
fear for my life
yeah between two ages yeah and then the
book The subtitle is the best part
because it's America's role in
technocratic Era he's not around anymore
but his daughter is of course Mika
versus evil on MSNBC oh wow um and uh I
confronted him specifically about him
talking about the great neural order and
him starting essentially Al Qaeda and
him being responsible for doing so in
American tax dollars with a foreign
policy move that bid us uh in the back
and also having culpability in the
events that happened in New York City on
9 11. so it was a very interesting
conversation uh watch it's the first
video I think if you go to my YouTube
channel we are change you go to the
oldest video you'll see that right there
but he talked about a lot of this
technocratic stuff what was your biggest
takeaway from between two ages
between two ages has essentially all of
the plan laid out in the 19 uh early 70s
and it caught the eye of David
Rockefeller so he talked to Kissinger
about this book and he's like I like
that guy get him in some kind of
steering committee yes yes we will do
that we'll create a steering committee
right away that's literally what they
did they had a conversation about that
was a good impression they created
trilateral commission and then boom uh
there's a big news there zbix they're
running it and he's basically from the
behind the scenes like you said doing a
lot of the uh the Black Ops and all this
kind of stuff but the book is really
just saying that all of reality will
have to change and we're right now and
he's saying the 70s in this position
between
the great reset right I mean he doesn't
use that terminology but it's the exact
same plan that's the point is like you
go all the way back to H.D Wells you
know 100 years ago and he was laying out
with Bertrand Russell in the Royal
Society in the fabians the socialist
society the exact same plan that
brzezinski's talking about it's it's to
the to a t yeah you know the funny thing
about it is like the the progenitors of
the New World Order and the great reset
and all this stuff are all very very old
or dead and the people they're giving it
to who are inhering it inheriting it are
incompetent and performance but they're
failing yeah they're fumbling and the
the plebs they were supposed to control
are are privy to what they're doing and
we're complaining about it and it's just
it's funny because I like I just want to
imagine you go back to like Jekyll
Island and all the weird plans and the
Federal Reserve and they're like well I
have absolute control and then 100 years
later they're grandchildren are
like I have no idea what I'm doing and
it's just all falling apart we're gonna
tell you what the metaverse
for the rest of your life your vitamins
will be souped into your body
I've explained this to people
you're going it's going to start like
this okay we're doing remote work we're
in lockdown number two just put on your
your metaverse headset sit in your chair
and then you're using the joysticks to
move around
a few years go by a few generations of
Virtual Technology no one will leave
their houses you'll wake up you won't
shower or brush your teeth because you
will already be in your pod when you
wake up you'll just click the button on
your visor and then you will be in the
front of your Virtual Office Building
and you a dragon will walk in where
hockey players are walking around
talking about sales pitch numbers and a
giant carrot walks up to you and says
look you didn't get the report done last
night I need the report when all sudden
his boss a rabbit walks over and says I
don't want to get any negativity today
we got a big important meeting cover
those reports then you walk into an
office where Super Mario is is doing
sales report meetings because
everybody's gonna identify in weird
weird ass ways and that's the weird
world you're gonna live in and get this
I shouldn't even say office building
you're going to literally walk into
Bowser's Castle and they're going to be
like we here at Funko sales we like
having a good time so our office
building is is Bowser's Castle and
there's you know princess and Mario were
talking in the corner or whatever it's
just weird and you're going to be
talking business in this crazy broken
world where carrots complaining about
stuff I was picturing people being fed
by tubes of like liquid fluid and uh
then their teeth falling out because
they don't brush them like you were
saying they're in the thing all day they
don't need to wash and clean the teeth
will fall out all of them will fall out
and then they'll start having kids with
no teeth no no no no
noons with no teeth I gotta stop you
people's teeth will actually get way
better because they won't be eating
breads and sugars first
or whatever it may be but we also have
to understand the internet is dominated
by a lot of adult content now imagine
having a VR and being in a place where
you're inundated with the internet and
you're going to be seeing a lot of weird
crazy stuff especially because people
can't kind of unhook and and get away
from it but Jay from your experiences
from what Tim just said how accurate is
that and how do you see the future kind
of shaping uh not by but what you want
but what you've read and what they're
calling for
yeah well that's the world I want right
that's I wanna I wanna right you want to
go to work at Bowser yeah right um your
boss is a dude but he Avatar says
Princess Peach and it's like just
Princess Peach is like look I told you
you couldn't be selling these things in
the office these digital widgets I'm
sorry Peach I mean Jim back to the
Brickyard with you smash him with your
head get it no I mean so the well in uh
Jacques de Lee's book brief history of
the future he has a section where he
talks about that when you're basically
in the pod phase you're gonna be
you're going to be bitched around
by a robot that will be your monitor
so I mean he actually it's all planned
out to where it's like you won't get
access to the outside world except
through this like bot monitor that
that tells you anything that you need to
know so that's kind of what the chat gbt
that's rolling out is this early phase
of what you see in movies like Spike
Jones is her
um there's also a really good movie that
makes Tim's point which is called the
Congress I don't know if you've ever
seen that but it's it's a classic with
uh in the Indie sci-fi movie from like
2010. it's got Robin Wright in it and um
they scan her in as an actress and the
company owns the scan she dies but then
like a thousand years into the future
everybody's interacting in the metaverse
as dragons and Mario and whoa It's
called the con it's called the Congress
yeah it's great I want to check that out
that's so funny part of why I'm obsessed
with these contracts what perpetuity is
everybody's in the metaverse like
wearing they're wearing the headset or
whatever it's in their head but
everybody's walking around in tattered
Rags like they're fentanyl zombies but
they're living in the metaverse so have
you seen the video on Philly of the that
drug epidemic or whatever where
everyone's taken so I wrote it's called
but they're all like shaking and
shambling back and forth It's called uh
Flocka no it's not flakka it's not
flocking now the Flocka one makes people
go like and go crazy the Philly one is
like trace or something like that and it
makes people like look like zombies
shaking back and forth I've seen this
too yeah you know in that book we were
just talking about uh brzezinski's
Between Two Worlds between two ages I'm
two ages I imagine the ages are the age
of the liberal economic order and the
age of the New World Order and that we
are in the middle of a transition but
you said mention the Fabian Society has
also been talking about this stuff
that's 1884 way before the liberal
economic order was formed I mean
technically I guess the British Empire
so is it what the British Empire is now
evolving into a world Empire correct
shrank it's called trank thank you so if
I could ask you uh sorry I I didn't mean
just grab the book on the Fabian but I
just wanted to ask you Jay because a lot
of people have different kind of
understanding and perspectives who do
you see at the top of the pyramid here
I know that's a very kind of open-ended
generalized question and kind of hard to
answer but I don't know if the Amish
I'm talking about the AQ not jokes
um no I think that so at the tip top is
a spiritual Dimension with the devil I
would think there's a real devil I think
that's the best explanation for why this
same sort of model like continues in
history to repeat
um but anyway beyond that I think that
when you look at these you know big
steering committees CFR Council Foreign
Relations if you look at
um Davos these are basically frontus
pieces for this inner core which is the
same structure that's been there it's
that secret security apparatus that's
set up uh you know no SS the CIA in 1942
1947 it's the British structure The
Milner Roundtable groups that's who's
running this whole thing so I I think
it's fair to say that there is a larger
spiritual and energetic component to
this that we definitely do not
understand but but it's interesting
because you just mentioned that they're
they're these kind of individuals are
calling for the same thing throughout
many different years in many different
decades I absolutely agree with you what
are they calling for exactly how would
you explain that to the kind of Normie
Kyle and Karen out there what are they
calling for what's the what's their goal
I think the elite ideology nowadays is
wedded to a form of extreme Darwinism
where it there's a social Darwin
darwinian attitude that if you are in
power you have the right to be in power
and that goes along with the the belief
that actually goes back to Plato and the
Republic that the human population has
to be kept at a certain level for the
Ideal Balance Plato's whole system was
based on Pythagoras's number mysticism
so there's a lot of hoodoo in that but
what what today's Elite have borrowed or
taken from Plato isn't the idea of
dialectics and part of dialectics is
that you have to do evil and good at the
same time yeah he also believed in
problem reaction Solution that's where a
lot of the larger kind of uh um
implementation of a lot of different
programs that they do Plato thinks that
Society should be controlled by a secret
society that lies to the public it's
called The Noble lie and it's a it's a
loose kind of technocratic model even
though he didn't believe it they didn't
know about technology per se and the way
that we do
in Plato's Republic you have discussions
of techne which is the same idea the
whole idea is that Society should be run
like a giant math program
and so Plato said the philosopher king
goes and studies on a mountain for 30
years and learns math and then he comes
back and he impresses upon the city on
the society the mathematical geometrical
principles of an ideal State that's what
the Republic is and then in later books
he says that actually it should just be
run by an oligarchy that is a secret
society all right so yeah and they have
to lie to the public and and Plato was
famous for eugenics for this idea of you
know keeping the population of real very
sustainable level
um and you you know he even says that
not to feed the the plebs meat they got
to eat rice they got to eat that sounds
familiar yeah I heard that before but
yeah that's Bill Gates's major pledge
wow and what they've been talking about
at Davos
um continue go uh we gotta get the
numbers down oh everybody's got to be
eating some kibble uh
kibble pretty much that's what they have
us eating dog food dog food is meat no
not not the chinese-made stuff there's
okay I don't know the dog food you're
getting for Atlas no I'm not getting the
Chinese man that's right good dog food
is meat a lot after World War II they
created dry animal food dog and catheter
used to be all meat and then they're
like we need to meet for the troops so
let's create some new Pharma thing
biopharma I don't know what is in this
bread that they're giving to cats
whether you think cat's not supposed to
be fat it's fat because it's eating
bread like and cats can't digest that
stuff yeah the carnivores feed your
animals have you tried Beyond kibble
I've got a new company called be gone
kibble sorry I used to uh Plato's like
one of my Idols but I just don't know a
lot of people that's good and bad in
Play-Doh why would you have an idol that
you don't know much about yo he thought
Cloud swap was a nice guy I mean I've
always looked up to the idea of people
like because of platonic love things
like that like this this concept that
you can have brotherly love with humans
is strictly platonic apparently um so
he's done a lot of good but apparently
and I love the idea of him sitting with
Socrates who's tripping out just saying
the most crazy stuff and he's writing it
down like yo I'm gonna this World's
Gonna remember this dude so would you
say like Plato is like the the Founding
Father of the of the Illuminati uh yeah
ultimately you're talking about that
Jay-Z thing that music group like the
Illuminati is like a vague generalized
term to talk about a lot of the powerful
people that that kind of roll things in
secret it's it's it's been popularized
by people like Tupac who've talked about
and made songs about it but it's it's
just kind of a name for the people
behind the scenes well it's funny you
said that because the origin of the
phrase Illuminati which comes out of the
French Revolution illuminated one it's
the illuminated ones and I've just been
reading this history of Byzantium and
the the Cambridge guy is talking about
how when platonism made a Resurgence in
Byzantium right when Byzantium was about
to fall uh they were called the
illuminated ones the Illuminati in
Byzantium the the radical play they were
atheist platonists and then they
influenced the Socialists of the French
Revolution the Jacobins who were the
Illuminati historically speaking is this
like the Hermetic Society too does that
all come from some of them were yeah so
plethon was the Byzantine platonist who
was a hermet associate
um and so it comes up to flash forward
to the future 19 1884 Fabian Society who
are the who's the Fabian Society and how
are they involved so this was created by
uh the Rhodes uh Milner uh circles uh
namely the Royal Society it's it's a one
of the offshoots of that um Cecil Rhodes
was the diamond De Beers magnate uh
working together with other uh Elite
banking families right and they sort of
set up a model for control that was
modeled on the British East India
Company Cecil Cecil's thing was diamonds
but that gave him the idea from secret
societies like freemasoners you create
his own society called The Society of
the elect and the plan was originally to
bring America back under the British
Empire
um they didn't really succeed at that
but what they did do was make alliances
with the wealthiest families in the U.S
who were all namely David Rockefeller
for example people who were not just
influenced by Von Hayek and Austrian
economics David was actually really
influenced by the Harvard socialist
Harold Lasky and that's what got him
into fabianism and that's why
Rockefeller for example was a big fan of
Mao like he wrote editorials in 1979 in
New York Times saying that Mao's
experiment was this great thing so the
wealthiest people that you could think
of in America JPMorgan Chase right
they're all funding and supporting
socialism even Brzezinski in between two
ages cites Anthony Sutton who's Anthony
Sutton's famous Professor wrote the book
uh Wall Street in the bolshik revolution
and Hitler and uh in Wall Street talking
about the elites funded these groups
right and especially the Bolsheviks and
the Communists and the Chinese
specifically and the Chinese Revolution
that was a major component of the
Rockefeller family that loved everything
that we're doing the whole cultural
revolution they they were loving seeing
all that the one child policy again
spurred on by a lot of these larger
eugenicists that are using China as
their larger playing Ground uh testing
out all this latest and greatest social
credit score technological enslavement
of human beings and a lot of people
believe China is separate and a threat
when in reality China has been taken
over by a lot of the western Elites that
are using it as a model for the world as
Klaus Schwab says China is uh the world
that we want to uh be envisioned the
model sorry I cut you off because I I
just I just I thought that yeah so the
the fabians are really just the
ideologues who took Marxism and wanted
to reform it and their ideology was was
better it was more successful more
useful than classical Marxism because
they were like oh the proletari will
rise up and then proletariat just cares
about going to lunch and eating their
lunch pail right they're not interested
in marxist's theory right so what the
the fabians realized was that if we
combine the Marxist Revolution with big
money we could have a lot more effect
and that's precisely what they did and
so Beatrice Sydney Webb George Bernard
Shaw they actually got to be really good
buddies with a lot of the American
Industrial us and Elites and they
influenced them including Henry Ford to
be into forms of socialism and so that's
why the whole push for the last century
is this sort of technocratic socialist
model so like can we can we just do the
same thing but like any other way can we
like get some prominent
libertarian-minded individuals to come
together to form a secret society that
bestows Liberty and shatters the
shackles and you know what I mean
like they did it can't we be like you
know me and Luke go meet will be like
how can we influence people to believe
in Freedom I guess we're doing it right
now so
yeah well you guys inducted me when I
got here right yeah it was eyes wide
shot ritual downstairs yeah yeah he had
to he had to swear an allegiance to
being a personally personal
responsibility personal responsibility
freedom and liberty so when they
sacrificed and I had to hit three
pointers down there so I didn't realize
yeah and he did and he did when they
started the Federal Reserve in 1913 it
seems like this is part of the movement
to bring the Americans on back under the
British Empire absolutely so and they
did and they did it with the bank of
international settlements in Switzerland
so they're going through Swiss banks so
is the British Empire intricately woven
with the Swiss banks now with a lot of
the stuff Davos is in Switzerland the
bank for international settlements which
is the Central Bank of central banks
it's the Federal Reserve of New York the
bank of England the bank of Australia
all go through the the bank for
international settlements in Switzerland
yeah how tight is this that was a even
though that was a post-war creation the
bis they created it post-war to be that
neutral kind of Central Bank of central
banks like you said
um and it's modeled exactly the same way
as the U.S federal reserves model which
is itself modeled on the bank of England
so it was all modeled uh in in regard to
The Milner Fabian circles who instructed
their dude
Colonel Edwin Mandel house who was the
Handler for Woodrow Wilson so that's why
all of this gets pushed under Woodrow
Wilson so the the League of Nations was
created to be that first attempt at
Global government government under the
Wilson Administration right they were
pushing that then that didn't it failed
and so they needed another world war and
then that led to United Nations and it's
the exact same people that set that up
but it set up by the by the same people
setting up the bis yeah and the land
that was donated for the United Nations
was donated by David Rockefeller who of
course played a very key role in setting
up this kind of international
institution that would bring all the
governments together in order to set
some kind of soft form of world
government and when you look at the
United Nations the way it was built a
lot of the kind of weird kind of occult
stuff inside of it it it it goes along
along with the same kind of larger
principles and ideologies that a lot of
these kind of satanists also kind of
profess and express what caused the
League of Nations to fail
uh didn't have any military prowess and
it was at that time they weren't able to
convince Americans to go along with it
so actually Congress didn't go along
with Woodrow Wilson's internationalism
that he was pushing but they did get the
bank pushed at that time right so it
took several more decades to get the U.S
to go along with this stuff and that's
the key role that a lot of the British
intelligence assets played including Ian
Fleming of James Bond Fame so
um William Stevenson of Canada who was
British intelligence in Canada he had an
office in Rockefeller Plaza Noel coward
the author you probably heard of him and
Ian Fleming were able to convince the
U.S to set up its secret security
establishment 1942 and they put Bill
Donovan as head of that that becomes
eventually the CIA right so that's that
secret establishment it's really just a
private Army The Rockefellers is what it
amounts to do you think this is a bit
more uh anecdotal but do you think that
they were like great better Global
powers that pushed Germany into World
War II and Hitler was kind of like a
useful idiot or did he actually seize
control and just go Rogue no I think
that he was funded by these families and
that if you read there's a whole chapter
that Quigley covers it's called the
appeasement plan so the British had a
dual Paul the British had a dual policy
where on the one hand they were secretly
supporting Hitler because they wanted
the war but then they were publicly
opposing him and that's because as
Quigley says and actually the dude from
Stratford agrees with this the the whole
20th century was to exhaust and get rid
of the anglo-american establishments to
main Rivals the Russia and the
Australian Empire the 20th century does
that particularly so the first two world
wars get rid of that cold war basically
depletes and gets rid of Russia that was
that key role that Brzezinski played in
getting Russia bogged down in the the
Afghanistan conflict and then they lose
the culture a lot of people need to
understand too that the United States
was very Pro Nazi and private I should
say the entire the country but uh
at the time was actually uh trialed uh
for supporting the Nazis uh there was
also huge stadiums in Madison Square
Garden where they had full-on Nazi
rallies that were that were filled to
capacity there was a lot of very
powerful individuals that were
bankrolling them financing them many
powerful corporations uh you know
corporations like Coca-Cola IBM
um and of course a lot of the bigger
influence from Hitler came from a lot of
the Eugenics
rockefeller-funded medical uh studies
and boards that of course he paid for in
finance that essentially created the
theory that Hitler was going on with his
larger uh genocide yeah look at this
look at this uh these photos from this
is from NPR this is crazy stuff yeah
that's Madison Square Garden Madison
Square Garden Nazi rally in uh was it
1939. yeah Henry Ford was also another
uh supporter when did the when did World
War II start was 1939 right I was gonna
yeah that's crazy yep and then all of a
sudden all the banks were like wait wait
we got to stop we gotta stop we can't
support the 1938 Hitler was Time person
of the year he was on Time Magazine Time
Magazine was run by Henry loose who was
Skull and Bones I got uh I went to an
antique store a couple of them uh in
West Virginia because there's tons of
people left antiquing out here and I I
was able to buy hundreds of Life
magazine going all the way back I got I
think I have the first issue actually
which was like a couple hundred bucks I
was really excited to get it and we're
gonna be putting at the new studio like
a viewing Library where you can go back
and read all of the contextual
perspectives it was it is crazy to read
about World War II before they knew what
was going on nuts in one of one of the
magazines they're like the U.S sent
defensive machinery and equipment to the
UK to prevent an invasion and it
basically shows the armaments for D-Day
like we now know the US was sending
weapons so they could storm the beaches
of Normandy back then it was reported
that they were just defending the UK Oh
you mean the news was lying to people
really well I mean look I don't expect
them to be like we're gonna invade the
whole thing was subterfuge played on the
Germans essentially so they didn't know
when they were coming or where they're
coming from it really is these magazines
are incredible to like read history in
the perspective of the day with no
foreknowledge
having the gift of hindsight to read
like it's it's just a crazy thing to
read someone a journalist be so wrong
about it it's part of why we need to
preserve our data and why censorship is
dangerous and why we need like external
sources of data collection because we
need like our our data should be in
orbit in glass in case a meteor
annihilates the surface so that we can
see what the mistakes we made along the
way and all the things like what you're
talking about how we manipulated our
enemies in the past how they can be
manipulating us right now do you think
that when the Soviet Union was falling
apart with this this concerted effort to
make the Russians and the Austrian
Hungarian Empire disappear that when
because I think when they split up the
Soviet Union the oligarchs or whoever
split it up gave the Black Sea to
Ukraine they took it away from Russia
they didn't want them to have
Mediterranean access so was that you
think that was intentional absolutely
That's a classic strategic area Ukraine
is right so uh Hitler had that as a
really important area when he was trying
to you know go against Russia
um but the cold war in my view was was a
managed dialectic ultimately I mean not
saying it didn't I mean my uncle was
like a you know Air Force guy in the
Cold War so I'm not saying that people
didn't do stuff but at a higher level
you know these are the people who wanted
there to be a dialectic between you know
Eastern capital or Western capitalism
and Eastern Soviet communism to smash
the two together and what you get out of
that is what's called a Third Way
synthesis and even back in the day in
the in like the 30s Burton Russell was
writing in scientific Outlook as a high
level you know Elite planner at the
Royal Society he was writing and saying
that he says quote the experiment in
Russia under Stalin is going great and
you'll find them talking about David
Rockler talks about Mao's you know
experiment these are experiments I think
of Technologies of governance they want
to see how they work I think I think
Nazism was the same thing and so they
find what works well in what regions
that's why the West is still promoting
you know azal Battalion and that stuff
in Ukraine now right I thought we're
supposed to be against Nazis right
America right but in the Ukraine it's
cool I mean it makes no sense right but
it makes sense a geopolitical strategic
standpoint so absolutely like the the
point was to deplete destroy Russia
ultimately for integrating every
everything into a technocratic order
that was the plan 100 years ago what
we're seeing now
so yeah it sounds like it was the plan
two thousand years ago with Plato but or
at least he was giving the philosophy
the plan hadn't yeah I think Plato
thought that you could have us like a
city state but I don't know if he
thought like the whole world would come
you know conform to this maybe he
thought that I think later plateness
like in the Middle Ages thought we could
take that model and it actually should
be the whole world I mean you even see
this in enlightenment philosophers like
you know Kant has a whole thing about
how to create a world government so
okay so where where are we going I guess
my question for you is with all this all
let's talk about the world economic
Forum everything they're talking about
doing they want to ban free speech
based on everything you've read where do
you think the next steps are where are
they going to try and bring us so a lot
of these books do talk about uh 10 20 30
year actuary plans so the next 10 years
is to get in things like the cbdc it's
to get in things like
Universal basic income if people accept
it um we had you know the Klaus and they
were running cyber polygons so and they
were just recently talking about
large-scale uh internet cyber outages I
mean when they run a lot of these drills
not always but a lot of times the drills
you know kind of pre-stage what's going
to come so I would say in the next 10
years we could we could expect that kind
of stuff we're talking about like a
cyber 911 yeah some some great
catastrophe what is that going to look
like you think phrasing of phrasing out
bank accounts we saw with the the
airlines they're saying some guy deleted
some files on accident but then we saw
the Bank of America thing where people's
money started disappearing they said oh
it was a glitch if if we actually got
some cyber shutdown
I remember there was this big thing in
the hacker committee people were telling
me about I'm not an expert many of you
listening maybe know it's called DNS
cash poisoning you guys might know about
that apparently there was this big thing
that happened
where uh domain DNS domain was it domain
name servers the the directory for the
internet had some kind of exploit and a
small group convened all the great
Powers the internet and said hey guys if
anyone finds out about this if this gets
out internet gets shut down and so they
secretly worked behind the scenes fixed
the problem and then came out and said
you guys had no idea how close you were
to the entirety of the internet going
down
if something like that were to happen
our economy would be overnight I mean
you you go to these small small cafes
and everything's digital you go to
Starbucks it's like who uses cash
but if the internet goes down you're not
doing transactions with a credit card
credit card will be piece plastic
nothing no way to transact any of this
stuff
I mean that could that would that I mean
I think that's a possibility for what
they may be talking about that's the
problem what's going to be the reaction
what's going to be the solution I think
that's the important thing to really
kind of uh look at here we were talking
about what what's happening with Bank of
America the FAA the Canadian FAA uh a
lot of people are kind of speculating
that there's a big possibility that
these are Ransom attacks it's also
important to note here that a lot of
these Ransom attacks are directly
because and I believe Edward Snowden
said this a couple years ago was that
the CIA and the NSA built specific
toolkits they built specific Online
weapons that could hack a lot of online
websites a lot of important key pieces
of infrastructure those toolkits were
just allegedly stolen and now any hacker
could get access to them was this done
deliberately was this something done
that uh was was just a part of a larger
plan here was this an accident was this
done on purpose I think those are
questions that people should be asking
themselves since these larger rants of
attacks that were in the news a couple
months ago especially affecting American
oriole Supply in the southeast of the
United States
we paid for these tools kits that are
being used right now for these Ransom
attacks people need to understand that
What's Happening Here was directly a
responsibility of some of the biggest
agencies in Washington DC when were
these toolkits taken
um I gotta I gotta look it up just to
give you a concise answer about this but
I believe Edward Snowden did a a big
expose you could definitely call it a
form of theft but it's more keep in mind
that they copied those tool sets so now
there's multiple copies of them floating
around it's all out there
future sounds fun and exciting
I don't even know I recommend I remember
I recommend getting out of cities buying
chickens maybe some goats like some
people say we're not even there won't
even be humans in 100 years at that
point I don't know if that's I did it I
did a segment talking about how we will
not be like if population collapses all
of the luxuries you know will be gone
like let me ask you a question how does
that TV up there work
do you know does that does that can
everybody can anybody give me a
fundamental explanation and I can look
at a computer processing a board but I
have no idea what where what copper gets
soldered where and gets twisted onto the
here's what I know the TV that's an LED
light emitting diode they're lined up
they emit colors I got no idea how you
convert you create a graphical user
interface if if the population collapsed
so what we there are people who probably
know how to make a screen an automatic
glass who know how to make a circuit
board that don't know how to make a TV
because it's all of the different
companies coming together that's the
problem with these replaceable Parts
factories in general is that people
don't know the entire process anymore
the artisanal labor workshops is gone
there's a function of reality no one
person can know how to make a toaster
now here's what I did say and and these
leftists tried mocking me for it we do
have laymen understanding of certain
things which will benefit us in
rebuilding if population collapsed like
like I don't know how to smelt or
anything like that or or or mine or or
make iron I couldn't make you a cast
iron skillet but I do know General
things I was shown by a geologist iron
rich or deposits iron rich mud and where
iron comes from and I have a basic
understanding of melting things down
because we've actually we got a crucible
and a kiln and all that stuff and we've
melted down Metals before but if I were
to try I'll put it this way
if the society collapsed me here and all
this luxury all this stuff will take me
years to figure out how to make a piece
of metal years now that's better off
than a tribal you know caveman or
whatever took them Generations so there
is that benefit but people don't
understand how much you will lose if the
grid goes down
yeah to answer your question in it was
March of 2017 Newsweek actually had an
article about this that was titled
Edward Snowden slams NSA over Ransom
attacks and essentially lays out the
argument how the NSA could have
prevented a lot of this but they acted
in a way that allowed these kind of
attacks to happen and to continue to
happen when they could have prevented
them and stopped them but they didn't so
it was it an accident or did they do it
on purpose for me I don't know we don't
have the evidence but I think they did
it on purpose yeah I'm now of the belief
that there is no monolith Within These
Industries within the NSA CIA American
government like there may be one guy in
that department that has a connection to
a CI to a spy in China that's making
calls that seem normal or slightly you
know and then you're like the entire the
entire thing's compromised at that point
I don't know how to how to stop that
never ever it's like globalization is
inevitable the more we are in touch the
more connected we become whether we want
to or not
by the way there's a uh and Rand
dystopian story that's like what you're
talking about where it's like I don't
know a hundred thousand years in the
future and they everything's everybody's
forgotten all the skills yeah and then
somebody like finds in a a cave stash
somewhere like planned so like how to
make something really basic Star Trek
next Generation they go to a planet
where no one knows how anything works
there's an AI that just controls
everything and they're like trust the ai
ai will keep us safe and just does
everything for us and they're basically
the adults are basically children they
couldn't tell you it's magic Logan's Run
have you seen that yeah yeah a long time
ago yeah they keep them young and dumb
they're as kids and then when you hit
age 30 you like float up into this oven
and get cooked because you can't live
beyond 30 right so yeah they have lights
in their hands and as you get closer to
30 it starts turning red and then when
you're 30 it flashes and then Logan's
like I don't want to die and then he
runs away
that's awesome that's where that's where
we're headed something like that
although if you're an elite you know
you'll live forever if you're a pleb
it's like the time machine you know like
the the H2 Wells yeah human civilization
splits into humans humans split into two
different species the smart and stupid
or whatever so we have more locks yeah
yeah that's right I think we'll
inevitably firstly I think that we are
going to evolve the ability to see
different frequencies so that we'll be
able to delineate what's what's natural
and what's artificial when we look at
like robots that are artificial
intelligence that look like humans we'll
be able to actually see the because when
I take psilocybin for instance the
artificial stuff is obviously artificial
the the life forms stand extremely out
so I think we'll redevelop that ability
to witness what's what's natural I don't
agree I think they're going to trick you
I think they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna find ways to control your
brain and I'm wondering if it's going to
be after 100 Years of enslaved that
people start to evolve this ability to
see
they're gonna put a chip in your brain
that's going to stop you from seeing
what they don't want you to see but you
said you said you were uh vibing with
some cockroaches so maybe are you
already seeing the frequencies
I've seen infrared light when I woke up
out of a dream one day my it was just
whatever my phone it was like light was
like I could see it was just all bright
red and then it like twisted and it went
it looked like it went into the phone
that's just because my perception was
closing around it and I was losing so we
had the ability to see what we maybe
think we can't well there are women who
can see I think what uh UV or is it is
it infrared which one let's see UV I
think right I don't know if it's UV I'm
not I don't remember which one it is but
it's one of those that just see more
colors because there's more
tetrachromats yeah yeah more cones in
their eyes they can see more colors and
it's only women yeah and that uh I guess
they say if you look up when a cloud is
passing over the sun look up and if you
see like purple around the edges your
attention I've seen that before
sometimes my eyes will go in and out of
this bro you can't you can't oh yeah you
can you can see purple around the white
light if you let yourself Ian uh I'm not
annoying about it okay I've done it many
times in my life perhaps fine what we
understand about the science is that men
can't be tetrachromax you can see all
the colors of the rainbow in white light
if you let yourself right and
tetrachromats mean they can see colors
you've never seen before yeah because
it's nothing like women were ones who
are hunters and gatherers and or 100
they were gatherers they were looking
for fruit they were looking for uh
things that were safe to eat they'd be
able to determine which was like just
the right shade of green what was the
wrong shade of green because there's so
many plants it looks so similar so over
time women involved the ability to see
things in a particular color men didn't
evolve that because they were Hunters
they didn't need that skill interesting
so I wonder maybe that'll be something
to do with telling if something's alive
or if it's a robot you'll be able to see
a color emanating off of it the other
thing I think we're going to evolve is
the ability to use our psychic abilities
to communicate with our thoughts again
like you know when you call your friend
on the phone and they're they're calling
it's busy because they're calling you at
the same moment I don't think there's
ever had that weird thing happen it's
happened to me many many times like more
than seven times in my life maybe maybe
you know maybe they say that gentle
mutation could only occur in women it's
because the gene for our red and green
cones on the X chromosome and women F2
men only have one
and if a manage genetic mutation in the
X chromosome and he only has one it will
result in him being colorblind rather
than tetrachromatic whoa no I don't know
that was crazy like the I could see that
if we build up our psychic abilities
better 12 of women psychics 12 that's
crazy psychic's kind of a loaded term
sounds woo-woo but if we figure out how
to communicate without having to rely on
our voices or writing like we'll be able
to bypass technocratic takeover if you
can protect your thoughts and choose
when to have thoughts and when not to
the machine's not going to be able to
read your mind because you have control
of when yo this is crazy look at this
these two pictures one is like a
painting rendition from a tetrachromat
and one is like a like a regular picture
so no you're saying that's what a woman
sees on the left that's what a
tetrachromat sees uh the small
percentage of women I guess 12 yeah 12
percent that's not at all what I see on
them Ian might be confusing it with an
acid trip
what happened I was looking into white
light and then I would see I would start
to see the rainbow staring at the sun it
would like turn into yellow then orange
then red then you know purple then black
then white then blue then green then
yellow then orange then red then purple
then black then white and it was like
out of the black would come white again
and it would keep cycling I'd keep
seeing all these just consider it I
don't know I'm weird you know there was
a lot of weed involved I'm sure but hey
that's part of our our our
what we are as well we have cannabinoids
in our brain our species fed off that
stuff right for for the entire existence
of it as far as we know for way back and
now they tried to cut us off of it yeah
true glass how are you talking about
Terence McKenna I will talks about the
stone ape yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I think
for sure our intelligence has evolved
along with our diet which happens to be
what we call today psychoactives or if
I'm good caffeine for instance is a
psychoactive you know if I'm gonna
believe any kind of crazy Theory without
evidence it's going to be that aliens
came and genetically engineered humans
between pigs and monkeys to make a slave
race because that just sounds more fun
and would make a good book
yeah yeah you guys ever hear that that's
like a conspiracy I don't know if
conspiracy theory is the right word
because it's not like it's not like just
a theory conspiracy theory implies like
humans did a thing together but this is
more just like a weird sci-fi idea they
believe that aliens came to Earth and
needed slaves to mine gold so they took
primates and pigs and hybridized them
and then added alien DNA to make them a
little bit smarter and that's what
humans are and I'm just like yeah that's
a lot to believe dude that's what that's
a big leap from a gorilla ate a mushroom
what do you think about the uh
conspiracy against marijuana from like
the 20s Harry J and Slinger are you
familiar with that I mean a little bit
the the pr campaign they did to make
people you know marijuana is bad yeah
can you explain it Jay
well I know from like dope Inc and books
like that that uh you know the British
Empire used drugs as a weapon obviously
you know against China and the drug
lanes that
were formerly controlled by like French
and British intelligence that was just
taken over by the West the Elites in the
West in our country right to run the
drug Lanes so I think that it's really
complex but I think that in regard to
hemp um if you're like I'm from
Tennessee Kentucky area so the history
of Kentucky was that was like a perfect
place to grow hemp and it was a you know
useful for all these different
things and it was uh intentionally
suppressed because certain chemical
companies you know wanted to have
monopolies over things that you know
hemp would put them on a business for so
I don't I don't think it really had
anything to do with the drug effects
they had to do with like the markets and
these these big corporations William
Randolph Hearst with paper newspaper
magnet he had trees on tree farms and he
wanted them to stop using papers is what
I've heard he wanted them to stop using
hampus paper and start using Pepper or
whatever his tree stuff check this out
check this out so this is uh a a
tetrachromacy test
you ever you've done these tests before
I'd imagine where they're like what
number is in the circle and then you got
to read the number but if you're
colorblind you can only see like one
shade it's the same thing by protect
your chromats so I just threw I just see
red green and orange that's awesome I
don't see anything but if you're a
tetrachromat you actually will see the
other colors now I don't know if the if
the monitor screen can emit those proper
colors to be honest but apparently
that's the point they're trying so
chicks is like birds what you're saying
yeah
they eat like birds too they tend to
swallow things whole you know women
those birds are real yeah
and so it says how could it be valid
computer screens only use red green
pixels I can't display the huge
attention permit would be able to see
right pigment and light are different
yeah so it's a fake test it's not
figment is a reflection of light
computer screen's not enough color
information to actually do the real test
ah sorry what I would see is like an
aura around it that would come out I
would see like a purple and then blue or
whatever depending on the oxygenation
levels if you're deoxygenated it's like
more yellow and the more oxygen you have
the Bluer it gets it seems to it's
called that acid flashback I don't think
so I never I never broke my brain with
drugs like I never went crazy I was
always slow to start and I've never done
more than like I don't know an eighth of
mushrooms at a time but some people like
people like I did multiple acid hits I'm
that no that's not my style that's crazy
I don't know unless you want to do it
let's uh let's jump to irreverancy we
have this story from Forbes Velma is the
third worst rated TV show in IMDb
history yo what were they thinking I was
listening to some reviews and I think
this is what Brett was saying over Pop
Culture crisis that basically the show
is hated by everybody and by Design like
you'd think the Velma show Frozen
familiar it's it's a prequel to
Scooby-Doo which retcons A Pup Named
Scooby-Doo which offended everybody bad
digress
you'd think that when they make a show
that's woke it's to piss off the right
to generate virality and then the left
would be like haha but I like it because
the right hates it nah apparently
they've made the show extremely a racist
offensive homophobic and gay at the same
time so everybody hates it I haven't
actually watched it but I want to I want
to explain exactly what I'm very very
mad about right so they they do this
this you know Velma thing where look at
this that's Shaggy okay this is Shaggy
now a lot of people are saying why is
why is Shaggy black and why is Velma a
Indian you know I gotta be honest I
don't really care all that much you know
I understand people get mad about the
ray swapping thing and I'm like they're
trying to make the characters diverse my
I guess the problem was they couldn't
make a black stone guy because Shaggy is
a stoner who eats a lot of food and does
drugs and so instead they made him
Norville they made him a beta male I'm
not exaggerating apparently like that's
a character Arc for him where he's a
beta male he likes velma's velma's
meeting him I'm gonna tell you why I'm
very offended by this because we just
got what's called Ultra Instinct Shaggy
and it was one of the greatest cartoon
developments ever like Ultra Instinct
Shaggy destroys multiverses so so uh
Warner Brothers puts out this video game
called multiverses
with two hilarious things
Shaggy is trying to eat a sandwich when
Arya Stark slices it in half and so he
basically goes Super Saiyan he's so
angry that he didn't get a sandwich that
he becomes Godlike and all-powerful and
that was just one of the funniest things
I've ever seen they got rid of that with
the stupid HBO show making him weak
Velma in multiversus her super ability
was to call the police on you and she
called the police on LeBron James who
gets arrested and then the cop drives
off the edge of the map and then you
know LeBron dies and uh they got rid of
that because it was offensive and it's
like guys you're hitting gold here these
are funny fun things that make us laugh
it's not a bug it's a feature instead
they're retconning and destroying
everything and making this weird garbage
Velma show that nobody wants to watch
it's supposed to be the history of Velma
like the before whatever the prequel
yeah but they they they made her fat fat
gay and Indian one of the criticisms is
that they they basically Mindy Kaling
who created this and plays the voice of
Velma the girl from the office if you
don't know she's in the office um
basically just inserted herself into the
show so this is like the Mindy Kaling
show in the guise of like Velma but it
has nothing to do with Velma or velma's
personality or velma's character from
what that's one of the criticisms I read
I still haven't seen it Daphne's Asian
and Fred is a a rich white guy with a
small dick yeah I'm not that's
apparently a part of the show I think
that's the only part of the show it's
like okay yeah now I just gotta say this
is proof that the global Elites are
trying to destroy him I'm kidding
there's no Scooby-Doo either yeah
what made Scooby-Doo Scooby-Doo was that
a stoned guy was eating dog food with
his dog that was just the funniest thing
you know yeah Shaggy was like oh I'm
gonna eat dog food now and you're like
it was like a little bit for everybody I
think you mentioned the diversity
there's a nerdy girl a hot girl uh a
stoner dude and like a jock dude
everybody could relate in some way to
that you know for the most part either
all white and then there's the the goofy
dog you know that you could be like okay
at least the dog was the best part I
used to like that series and now to have
someone just try to reinvent the wheel
take it over and make it theirs and
destroy it it's just like okay one think
of an original idea stop trying to
hijack all the other Classics out there
I'm also hearing that there's a two
minute long scene where allegedly 15
year old girls are butt naked and
fighting each other in suggestive
positions uh yeah because they're all
like they're like high schoolers I think
yeah so like lots of inappropriate lots
of crazy stuff here I only played it
just to just to kind of see a little bit
of it and I'm like this is this is
insane I can't believe this was just
this was okayed by people I can't
believe this was like yeah this is the
big news today like we're starting the
show I'm like look what's the big news
and he's like Velma Velma apparently
everyone is mad everybody's mad they
ruined Scooby-Doo yeah and I'm you know
my thing is outside of the Velma stuff I
think this is the
the the Apex the center of the Maelstrom
that is the collapse of
our culture
we've we've we've regurgitated and
beaten subject matter and and themes to
a point where we've made this like we
keep rebooting Spider-Man every couple
years we keep rebooting Batman
Transformers there's nothing original
left there's no new music I mean look
look I bring this one up Christmas time
comes around we listen to the exact same
songs from the 40s and 50s right it's
like yo there was a period where those
songs were new and granted we got like
that Mariah Carey one all I want is
Christmas for All I want for Christmas
is you but for the most part very little
new things are being developed we are
stagnant and this is like okay now it's
crumbled to Ash they keep remaking
Scooby-Doo they make new Scooby-Doo
movies they make you know Scooby-Doo in
the video game and we're like we get it
man these characters are all you have
now you know you make a copy of a copy
of a copy just gets worse every time
we're at the point where you can't even
decide you're just like what is this
it's like you take a menu from
restaurant you copy it then you copy the
copy and it's kind of grainy then you
copy the copy and you're like it looks
like gibberish and you copy the copy and
it's smudge that's what this is It's
just done it's done I don't know where
we go from here without Scooby-Doo well
you cut opiates out of your diet if
you're taking them that's one way to get
your creativity back
but but they destroyed the the core
element of the show which was the kind
of sense of of a friendship this friend
this like this sense of like Hey we're
gonna figure out this problem together
we're gonna work together and that was
that was you know it was cool to see all
the teamwork but now this show from what
I've seen from the first episode is I'm
a strong independent woman I'm gonna
solve everything and I'm the best
doesn't she like murder some dude or
something in the trailer she like
murders a guy that was another big
criticism is that they'd only like each
other yeah they hate each other and they
keep like fighting and ridiculing each
other and making fun I like each other's
private parts even though they're like
supposed to be 15 years old I like that
Family Guy joke where Peter says
something like it's almost as as scary
as the Scooby-Doo Murder Mysteries and
the murder files or whatever and then it
shows like now back to Scooby-Doo Murder
Mysteries and then Fred is like he
gutted the victim removed his intestines
and then strangled him with it we're
dealing with one sick son of a
just the idea of like the actual mystery
involving murder for Scooby-Doo would
just be hilarious yeah
you know what's funny about Scooby-Doo
is the mystery was always that like some
real estate developer was trying to drop
property value to like yeah every time
and so he dressed up like a ghost to
scare people so they wouldn't buy the
property you know people do they just
shoot guns in their backyard property
value drops I wouldn't be surprised if
they're trying to save Scooby for uh
um season two and uh they're probably
gonna make him a pit bull and they're
probably gonna make the Pitbull attack a
bunch of babies yeah I guess with the
way the show's going I see that as an
actual plot I have a feeling they're
gonna uh oh baby exists Scooby's first
appearance would be the last episode of
the first season it's just so so obvious
and predictable would have been at the
end of the first season they probably
already have it planned out they're like
I'm so excited dude if you're if you
is crap it doesn't matter what your
plans are because it ain't gonna work
this Show's not gonna last more than six
episodes I mean maybe they're already
made don't don't mark my words on that
but it's the third lowest rated
television show in history on IMDb at
the moment I don't know how many votes
are in on it 1.3 out of 10. look at
these good luck it's I think it's worse
than Santa Inc which is whoa Santa
remember that yeah that is impressive
the Seth Rogen Sarah Silverman it's the
fifth worst rated thing on IMDb
they seem to have badly scraped the idea
of an elf wanting to become Santa Claus
or Scooby could be a furry right
a part of the the acceptance movement
and then and then they could be Velma
and Scooby could be getting it on dude
if it was a guy that got imprisoned and
genetically experimented on and turned
into a dog but you gotta do that in
episode one because that would be cool
maybe that's what they're doing like
Norville is actually gets turned into
Scooby and that you know and that that's
why he's not Shaggy oh and they think
the real shaggy is but he's like I can't
tell him the truth it's part of the
experiment I turn a dog into a guy and a
guy into a dog and that's the origin of
Scooby-Doo and that's why he can talk
because hey why can Scooby talk it makes
sense he's a chimera he's a kid I have
no other explanation like why can't we
get just something original I guess you
got to make it well Eric July made that
made the rep reverse stuff so you know
there's people trying you can try yeah I
still think a psychic gorilla is gonna
be the next big superhero what do you
mean psycho rat's Grodd grad is a
villain but is he a space gorilla
Gorilla Grodd is from gorilla City and
he's he can control people's brains and
he's a bad guy and he's psychic we need
a cosmic gorilla good guy that's a
psychic you know what's kind of funny in
Marvel they have wakanda which is like
you guys know what kind is wakanda
wakanda yeah like in in the the country
of wakanda in Africa they have a force
field they hide in DC they have Gorilla
city which is like basically the same
thing but everybody's a gorilla
I'm like I wonder why they did that you
know I mean that's it seems kind of
weird oh my gosh yeah it's like wait a
minute hold on a second yeah that's what
DC made I wonder like who made it first
because they would do this thing where
like Marvel has a DC I think I can't
remember who did it first I think maybe
Slade
so there's two characters there's
Deathstroke and Deadpool and they're
very similar characters although
Deadpool eventually became comedic and
Deathstroke is a very serious character
Deathstroke is DC Deadpool is Marvel
and so they talk about how there's like
always this back and forth I I always
wondered about that like the analog for
wakanda is a gorilla City like was that
racist yes it sounds like it but I don't
know which came first gorilla City or
wakanda I don't know I don't know but
Gorilla Grodd was a bad guy he wanted to
take over the world because he he was
basically killmonger but a gorilla
that's kind of weird to me Jay what
would a philosopher say about this uh
incredible content and entertainment
that is of course fed to the American
public
uh my thought was this is it's maoist
like the way that this has to be pushed
and it's always like going a little
further like the dogma of this right and
you know maoism is a cultural revolution
to change everything that came before so
I just see it as kind of like a
rewriting of everything even down to the
point of like the most mundane pop
culture stuff has to be Rewritten has to
be revolutionized in that way right like
getting rid of all the four olds like
all the old culture old religion I don't
think it's it's kind of what's Happening
Now all the old things are like you are
unacceptable you can't have them and if
you redone remade we've been watching my
wife and I've been watching old like 40s
movies which it's amazing the degree
even in those of propaganda that existed
like particularly warprop again the
americanist propaganda but in terms of
like ethics is they're all pretty
wholesome you know 40s era stuff is I
mean compared to like what's now but
it's just bizarre to see how far it's
gone from like 40s era to now like the
the revolution is complete and they're
actually gonna I think they're gonna
start like Banning
movies that are before a certain date
like you won't they're gonna say you
can't I mean Bruce Russell talks about
that he's like you're not going to be
reading Shakespeare in the future you're
not going to read Mark Twain You're
going to read Flannery O'Connor you're
not going to watch you know movies
before a certain date or they'll be
purged in some way or edited in some way
so that's right Disney already has
warnings saying hey this this movie is
racist like Snow White exactly which is
absolutely crazy preservation of data
we'll have to hide our data it's
literally we'll have to store our data
in Hidden like glass cubes in orbit
things where you can if you get the
coordinates hit it with a laser and read
the data or something like that we're
really gonna have to protect our data I
didn't think it was going to come to
that but we do not only from asteroids
no wait there apparently Scoobies in the
show but it's
s-c-o-o-b-i and it's some black chick
what really oh that's what people are
saying is that even a dog no it's sort
of insinuating yeah exactly what are
they saying oh right is that for real
I I think it automatically changed
Scooby back to what we're talking about
Scooby-Doo last year I forgot oh it was
the LeBron James oh yeah pop culture
crisis covered it Scooby Scooby Velma
turned Scooby-Doo into a black woman
yeah what that's kind of weird why would
they that's racist it kind of has Scooby
that's her name her name is Scooby and
and Norville dates her oh man pop
culture crisis covered it look at that
what Scooby's like doobie right Scooby
Dooby you know smoking that oh yeah
what's Scooby Dooby Doo that dog was on
drugs
but they're like figuring out right
so they're like they're real they're
like you know the guy in the uh Cabin in
the Woods like the the guy that's the
stoner guy but he actually figures
everything out yeah that character oh
wasn't it like the weed was a lot of the
Breakthrough and see what was going on
but like no they're really controlling
us the puppet Master's right and there
really were Republicans yeah that movie
was awesome I remember when people
someone I remember was like Hey when the
movie came out people were asking me
have you seen Cabin in the Woods I'm
like I'm gonna go see that movie like a
movie dumb teenagers go to the cabin in
the woods and get murdered and they're
like that's not what it's about you know
I've noticed about smoking I went to go
see it for those that aren't familiar
it's about a Trope of people that the
the Scooby-Doo gang the nerdy girl the
hot girl the Jack and the stoner going
to a cabin and then there's a gigantic
underground complex of people trying to
sacrifice them to moloch or whatever
yeah that's correct that's the old ones
yeah the old ones that was funny what I
found was fun with weed and the value of
it in like perception because you know
it does change your perception is that
it's kind of like holding a magnifying
glass and and the more you smoke the
further away the glass gets so you want
to get it to right the right position so
that you can see the thing but if you do
too much it becomes blurry if you don't
do enough it's still blurry kind of
things you want a Scooby Snack dosing
every day dog I think dosage the key in
the whole drug war it's not about the
drug it's about the dosage of the
content like what is the chemical what
is the dosage fentanyl is not going to
kill you in the right dosage
but the unfortunate thing is that
conversation probably hasn't been
highlighted enough yet and the dosage is
like overlooked in some situations I
don't want to manifest that because we
can focus on dosage yeah but I think
there there's so many psychedelics are
are going to be a key component in the
preservation of our species moving
forward Against the Machine feels like
it anyway
that is hijacked the conversation
we're talking about Scooby Snacks I
think and then we're talking oh yeah
yeah you get me on Shaggy I'm gonna go
nuts yeah
I mean there's like the whole of the
whole theory about like kelp yeah I
think it's Paul stamis said that we ate
we ate um psilocybin mushrooms and that
like made us then you know see things
then think more and it allowed our brain
to develop because it increased like the
connection between neurons etc etc
that's what Jay was saying with uh
Terence McKenna and it's called The
Stone Dave the Stone Age I think it
originates with Terence McKenna yeah
okay and then stametsu is a fungologist
or whatever you call the greatest
Mycologist Mycologist on Earth Paul
stamets all right we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com no members only show tonight
but we do have them up Monday through
Thursday so be a member to support our
work and watch the massive library of
members only content and uh we're gonna
read what you guys have to say
not of this Earth says glad to see the
based Chad nerd himself on timcast after
years of requesting you it finally paid
off there you go he's here I told him
harass you they worked they worked
Society remastered says Tim I ask for
your help as a fellow Freedom lover and
believer in this country's potential New
Mexico house bill 50 bans 10 round mags
please let your viewers know so this
cannot so that so that it can be opposed
we need a Supreme Court ruling on that
that should be unconstitutional
those are low capacity magazines
standard capacity is 30 and that's not
hyperbole it's not propaganda quite
literally when you when you pick up a
new rifle it comes with a 30 round mag
it'll come with 10 10 or small yeah
they're trying to play games
play games man
all right Raymond g Staley JR says a
special shout out to the OG of change
Luke we always dig your visits heck I'm
nearly small L now hearing your rants be
well until the next visit when Dan
finally shows his face team Luke milkers
did you hear that Luke I just heard that
Team all the way uh Luke's gonna be here
on Monday uh yes that was requested to
be here so yeah Luke was like I'm
leaving and then I was like Stephen
Crowder's coming on Monday goes I'm
staying no that's exactly what happened
I'm like Jesus I'm like I don't know I
was like you should go you should go no
no exact opposite of that happen but I'm
starting a website uh the real og.com
and it's going to be really fun I'm
going to launch it Monday and stay tuned
and thank you so much for that I really
appreciate it and uh means the world to
me seriously all right blue heart says I
still own an unopened box of mix and
bottle of syrup from Uncle Jeremiah
Jeremiah uh I have a I I was when they
banned Aunt Jemima I went to the gas
station and I saw they had a box of it
they had one and I grabbed it and I'm
like I'm buying this I mean I don't know
if it's gonna last long or whatever no
but like Pokemon was it called Pearl
Mill Pearl Mill pancake Pearl milk
Company Pearl Milling Company Pearl
Milling Company oh wow it just rolls off
the tongue when I wake up in the morning
you don't really piss me off about Angie
Mama stuff
I was saying this in an earlier segment
that picture of that kindly woman
smiling on that box of Pancakes gives
you this feeling that when you wake up
in the morning there's a nice lady who
loves you and has cooked you a hot
breakfast and she's makes you feel good
but they're like it's racist what's
racist about a nice smiling woman who
made breakfast for you that's
heartwarming or Uncle Ben famous chef
cooked you a hot meal because he cares
about you nope gone but the bald white
guy who's ripped and wants to clean your
floor nobody has a problem with that Mr
Clean Mr Clean yo come on man
they just want to take take all the fun
away and like the I said the Lando Lakes
Native American lady she's like holding
corn or whatever I don't know on the
like they use a Native American Woman as
a symbol of natural and Purity and
goodness and they're like gotta get rid
of that yeah why why they were they were
saying that they had the best butter
because it was associated with the
wholesomeness and cleanliness of the
natural and assessing that with Native
Americans it was a net positive it's a
positive view yeah but you said she was
a seven earlier
no I said she was a 17 bro I said she
was off the charts I think she was
holding a box of butter is that what she
was holding a box in them later
it's funny because you like whitewashed
themselves Seth weather says time for a
reminder eat steak lift weights and be
uncensorable screw the government
Miss butterworths Miss Butterworth
wasn't even black yeah she was maple
syrup and they got rid of her I think
they got rid of the Miss Butterworth
look that up because they said it was
racist because she looked like a black
woman the color of the glass was like a
dark tinted Brown because the color of
the syrup or the plastic oh yeah
did they get rid of they got rid of his
butter words right I think so I feel
like weird that's superstitious like
it's turning to where colors are
inherently evil yeah it's like
Superstition all I'm saying is we got to
reclaim these Brands so look I took what
used to be the independent skate logo
because they abandoned it and don't want
to use it anymore because I think it's
racist so I'll use it but I recommend
all of you out there start your own
company start using these trademarks
make uh aunt jemimas whatever you you
got a golf ball company make Angie
Mama's golf balls and put her face on it
not a bad idea what are they gonna do
about it they abandoned it they don't
want to use it anymore it's not the name
they use you lose you can't keep a
trademark you don't use it expires
you're gone it's free take it back yup
free real estate
all right what do we got red Drew Mac
says you need to make some female
t-shirts Luke with cleavage I would not
buy those strangled shirts strangled
shirts we have women's t-shirts we have
tank tops they want low-cut where the
boobies I think we have that we have the
we have the uh you know we have them for
moobs we have them for boobs we have
them from all the moods that you might
be in
um and you just gotta click on the
different styles on the left hand corner
we have them all lined up for you and
then we have those tank tops as well
what are those things that the dogs put
over their their back like with pockets
in them that'd be cool like uh like a
dog a dog merchandise yeah yeah it's
cool
all right so you guys telling the ATF to
stay away from them yeah the great
treasure says Ben said what I was
thinking on a show today no friend would
ever do what Crowder did lucky Ben and
daily wire crew are stand-up guys a
public apology would help the Friendship
move forward his only hope what is what
someone said that Ben was Crowder's
lawyer like his first time I saw that is
that true I don't know
I mean I just gotta say like
the way I put it earlier in my morning
segment
Crowder is ideologically correct but I
think tactically wrong ideologically in
that
the daily wire shouldn't be penalizing
you for being banned from the mainstream
media from the from the big Tech
platforms if they're building a
subscription company
you know what I mean that being said the
daily wires response was like well
Crowder should have just said that take
that out and do this but ultimately the
daily wire said no to his terms so it's
like it's not like Crowder you know
Crowder did come back and say this deal
is no good you need to do a better deal
and credit did tell them like why are
you docking pay this was Carter's
argument why are you going to penalize
me for YouTube Facebook Spotify and and
apple when you're trying to build a
membership platform that's like so I
bring it up 300 000 members but then you
take my money away because YouTube bans
me that makes no sense he's right
my view of the daily wire is that
they're just doing like you know more
generic corporate contract approaching
kind of stuff I don't I don't know how I
feel about the uh secretly recording
Jeremy thing you know I'm fine with it
personally I don't care Texas assume all
your calls your calls are already
recorded no one's arguing legality we're
arguing are you a good person yeah but
that's what business is about business
isn't about are you a good person
business is hard numbers then the point
here is that the daily wire is like yo
this is a friendly phone call where we
talked about our families and then
Stephen Crowder recorded it like the
argument is not was a business but to be
fair the daily wire did say its business
so they put that on themselves that you
can't say it's just business but also we
were friends you know what I mean
so yeah I'm looking forward to the
future of it I love it I'm looking
forward to them hanging out but I'll
I'll put it this way the daily wire
wants to be a big entertainment company
similar to like what Hollywood has they
just want to produce better values
Stephen Crowder wants to build more of
what Ian and I were talking about where
if you're a young person starting up and
you and you create a brand you keep
those members when you leave the company
those members go with you I think what I
would what I would imagine is that you
know Crowder builds Up Mud Club and then
when the contract ends they're like now
you have nothing and he's like are you
kidding me I did all the work I built
all this up and I have nothing to show
for it and they're like well we were
paying you we bought it so what Crowder
is saying is we need to build a system
where when some 20 year old kid signs a
contract it says when you leave you
retain what you built with your members
and that's more of like what Ian and I
have been talking about with a
decentralized locals patreon kind of
system
not to keep going on about that subject
I'll talk more on Monday I know yeah
yeah
Adventurer says get chickens get goats
get carbureted Vehicles grow potatoes
distill ethanol Independence is a scale
take it one step at a time and right now
what you should do is on your phone's
download three different survival guides
then whatever backup device you have
download three there purchase some
emergency jet phone generators thing
they have things you can like hand crank
to generate power they're
and it's not easy to do to chart forever
man but it's worth it you know you'll
get a radio signal if you need it yeah
and the thing about a phone is if the
entire grid went down but you had a
smartphone with 100
turn the volume all the way down turn
the brightness all the way down and then
open up the survival guide and start
learning as fast as you can and conserve
that power on that phone because whether
you use the phone or not the power is
going to fade from it yeah I created a
survival guide called the apocalypse
survival uh it's a Master Class A Part
of Lucan sensor.com my membership and at
the click of one button you get to
download all of it so just in case if
there's like an EMP or no internet or no
Wi-Fi or or no no star link you could
have all the videos uh and uh
information available to you at hand
here's an important one Trident 54 says
Chessa Boudin parents whether
underground killed three that's right I
knew there was some story about that it
was like a bank robber or something or I
can't remember you guys want that up
yeah I have a master class on philosophy
which you're going to be talking about
philosophy when everything collapses
there's nothing else to talk about right
yeah you either read books or talk about
flaws well no you'll be farming all day
and doing work now and talking about
philosophy at night and trading bottle
cops no you work until until until your
hands bleed yeah people don't understand
this if you get people to work for you
then you can just hang out and talk
about if if we lost the grid yeah you'd
be working like 6 a.m to 10 p.m so maybe
like the hour before bed like you'll
stop to eat over dinner you know when
you stop to eat and have dinner before
you get back to work you'll be talking
philosophy there we go unless you're too
tired if you're lucky to have dinner if
you're lucky to have dinner well you got
to be farming Non-Stop part of what I
try and keep people stupid fatigued and
afraid because they don't have the
mental capacity to talk about philosophy
yeah okay I said they keep the people
they encourage people to do things that
keep themselves in that state
no one's forcing you all right the new
GM says if 1 20th of Crowder's Subs went
to daily wire that's 250k at eight
dollars a month over four years equals
96 million it's unlikely loud with
Crowder would lose DW money at 50
million if a small Channel took a 500
000 deal or four years those Max
penalties could put the fee at 30k a
year
the same as full-time Burger flipper
the the issue is which you got to
understand Crowder is coming out and
saying
we have 350 000 members and everyone's
just going 350 000 times 10 bucks you
know that's 3.5 million per month he's
going to make way more than they're
offering that's a lowball offer and it's
like whoa slow down
we don't know Crowder has that Crowder
believes he will have that but the blaze
isn't releasing the numbers and
you know that's the issue
maybe he's right I personally think
Crowder will probably get more than that
but
the daily wire came out and said we're
not convinced so you were right about
Chester boudin's parents Kathy Bodine
and David Gilbert were Weather
Underground members uh when Boudin was
14 months old they were both arrested
and convicted of murder for their role
as getaway car drivers in 1981 Brinks
robbery yeah
loktar says Tim you watch Comet TV don't
you I do that every day you mentioned
Outer Limits episodes and SG episodes
that have been on around the same time
they've aired great Channel you are
correct I used to watch three episodes
of sg1 every day because comet would air
them all back to back amazing show I
don't really watch it anymore I don't
really watch it it was good we my wife
and I wrote as we had a TV show we did
one season of a TV show that was on Gaia
analyzing movies and we wrote a whole
second season and we were going to do uh
Stargate in the second season analyzing
and breaking it down like the movie or
sg1 the TV show the TV show is just
brilliant yeah good show yeah we had um
corn Nemet came to hang out and we did a
bit with Ian what's up Corin where uh
Ian Parker Lewis and
um the gag was you know Ian was
convinced he was actually working on the
Stargate project and he was like Ian I'm
just acting but he kept doing things
where like Ian would overhear him
talking about building a machine and
then finally at the end he walks out and
then he's like I got permission from Tim
to build a Stargate here and then the
Stargate opens in front of him you see
the light flickering you know it really
broke my heart to see that bit that we
did because I'm like
years later with Stargate sg1 and all
that over we got a tiny 30 second morsel
of Life of Stargate su1 from a joke that
we did and that was it and it was just
like seeing the light shine for a brief
moment before fading out I'm like man I
love that show I mean I only watched in
the past few years it's like I watched
it back when it came out I think
society's primed for a good Sci-Fi
Sam
all right the new GM says you guys been
following the DND ogl situation if not
you should do something on it I have
been not not closely though but I I
don't know where they're at right now
but thanks for bringing it up again we
got to make that game the Crosslands
yeah man that's on my mind almost every
day people keep reminding me it's it's
such an interesting simple concept there
are six paths of where the different
planes cross it's the Crosslands and uh
and there you go are you the game master
yeah okay I see the dice over here yeah
yeah yeah uh yeah we're talking about
making a new game Crosslands my last
name so the Crosslands where it's like
the uh the meeting of all these
different dimensional Dimensions it's
kind of like a world where you can exist
in the middle of all these different
worlds I love that idea because every
episode every every game could be
whatever you want it to be you can go
through a portal into any real anything
it's it's it's it's a similar like in
Magic the Gathering it's like you're a
planeswalker traveling through different
realities or whatever the Crosslands is
at the intersection of the Multiverse
you know you draw you can summon
creatures from through the portals and
things like that so I don't think I've
ever played Chrono Trigger but you can
go to the end of time and create a
trigger that's kind of my my inspiration
the lamp post and the guy's just
chilling at the lamp
was like one of the best games ever made
and Chrono cross just couldn't cut it
you played running across he had nothing
nowhere near us exactly the music for
Chrono Trigger the music's a big part of
it man true they they they tried though
they couldn't get it but uh we'll make
the Crosslands tabletop RPG and side
card game component
and then we just uh we fix we make a
different uh cocktail trading card game
that improves upon magic and does it
better and then we don't do any of these
garbage licenses where it's like we own
the content you create or anything like
that and we make it an open source game
where it's like
play the game how you want to play it
you know yeah I'm still well I'm talking
about stuff yeah I'm thinking about like
okay yeah thanks
what do we got Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Ian's Klaus is nearly as good as Tim's
AOC you mean my Nancy Pelosi
I don't think I have a very good AOC
impersonation I think your Nancy Pelosi
is really good yeah I do a killer Maxine
Waters oh yeah let's hear it uh is that
safe to do no I guess I like doing Nancy
Pelosi because she is a decrepit evil
woman and she talks like this and Donald
Trump is ruining this country Klaus says
is ours with the back of his throat so
thaw with the th is a real thing and
then it's when you say um
to take over this country because
there's not a problem
well if I was to do Maxine Waters she
says go out and attack everybody find
the Trump people at the gas stations
attack them
that's what she said right she said get
in their faces get in their face get in
their face yeah all right let's read
some more
um what do we got here
Jeffrey Adams says Klaus is not
interested in the fourth Industrial
Revolution he is bringing in the fourth
Reich
jeez it makes sense do you think he's
like a pup kind of a puppet a face or do
you think he's a ringleader in this
entire process I think he has a pup a
front role to play but not at the top
because uh he was recruited through the
Harvard project which was a CIA
operation by Kissinger so Kissinger's
who spotted Klaus so I think he's kind
of a front for the whole that whole
Nexus Roger page says why would our
teeth fall out the people in the Middle
Ages didn't brush their teeth and their
skulls have better teeth than I do
because they didn't eat the processed
garbage they ate meat and drank milk
neck cheese
yeah right eating might actually not
eating might help your teeth man
chickens are awesome I got a picture of
a chicken right behind me all the time
because chickens are amazing they're
funny they're stupid
they have little personalities they're
all different and they give you eggs
they eat the bugs they live in the Pod
and they give you eggs it's fantastic
I know we're way past this but I
remembered that if you if you remember
scream let me watch yeah right scream is
this it's like Cabin in the Woods before
cabin in the woods and I had a did an
interview with Jamie Kennedy you would
you would dig talking to him you should
have him on sometimes no it's really
funny dude he's like super red-filled oh
wow cool
yeah we got to get more uh people who
are in you know willing to speak out and
stuff
all right let's see Big Mike says first
time super chatting Tim can you tell me
your opinions on ancestry DNA testing
it's a really cool and Nifty thing and
then they have your DNA in their system
for the CIA and they can use to make bio
weapons that Target specific people so I
don't know I'm just trying to figure out
the Bond movie right no time to die was
that they could take the tailor the bio
weapon to specific DNA yep yeah wasn't
there another more recent movie or is
that was that was that the recent one it
was the no time to die like that last
year there was uh what was I watching
what was it
I can't remember I was watching some
show where
what what should oh oh oh fridge fridge
on Fringe there was a guy who was making
a chemical that would Target specific
people's DNA or whatever so he would
release it and it would only affects
certain people or something like that
yeah yeah it's kind of giving away your
password crazy it's wild that people are
offering up encrypted I uh I did learn
due to uh other family members who took
their ancestry DNA that I'm actually
part Japanese
that was funny because it's like I'm I'm
uh 20 Korean and five percent Japanese
and you know why that is right yes
uh you know you guys liked each other
you guys were neighbors that's right
they were very friendly right absolutely
that's it you know just hey Japanese
these guys coming over and then they
were like howdy neighbor and they were
like you look kind of like me let's be
friends and have families the Japanese
people are like oh they hooked that's
exactly what happened they totally have
a very peaceful peaceful relationship
throughout the uh it's funny because
like whenever I tell people I found I
was part Japanese they go oh
yeah we know about that
I'm like well you know whatever that's
why I like anime I guess
what just happened YouTube just crashed
over here I'm I'm 10 uh Dutch
not Dutch uh Danish so I'm like 90 90
polish but 10 data so that must have
been some kind of Viking dude
hey we're coming over long time not even
that long ago 10 yeah
I don't know if it was that long ago
it's probably just some dude coming to
hang out hey I got a super chair here
from Richard Grove just came in yeah
he's awesome he's a code dude oh nice
thanks for inviting Jay to bust up
klausen's the Gang
uh more books and deep Dives like this
please excellent guest
thanks Richard yeah Richard does his own
podcast as well Grand Theft world
all right Damien Simmons says name Noble
new but from future came to this world
from the Crossland my world was taken
over a massive VR game drop one day an
update happened if we took headset off
it would explode inside were humming
devices that would send a code to a big
Boomstick many loss
like I that per that was very confusing
but it got me thinking about the
Crosslands I kind of want to write a
book about it the Crossland you you have
to set the set the meta yeah and it
could be it could be the Multiverse and
time though of course space time is the
same thing right the the cross lands and
it can be like the moment
Humanity discovered the Nexus point to
the Crosslands it opened up all of
reality and and time basically didn't
exist anymore
because I was I was reading this thing
about uh the concept of time travel
it said once time travel is discovered
if possible time will no longer exist
because people will move through time as
if it's space and everything will be
always yeah it's the craziest thing
yeah so like let's say you're like I'm
gonna make I'm gonna make a fine a
12-year whiskey you'd make it and then
open a door to 12 years and pick it up
and it's just like the craziest thing
you know and like it's just there
instantly you have it yeah that'd be
cool but that means that when it comes
to the game itself it's easy to do
different worlds and different themes
for different sets so it doesn't have
you know the problem with magic the
Gathering is all fantasy and I always
talk to my friends about this if they
did a Modern Warfare game that was like
soldiers infantry bombers generals and
it was like you know World War II world
war three Iraq Wars like era of of War
but in a magic the Gathering style card
game it would attract more players for
sure I know a lot of people would be
like oh I don't want to play that weird
you know cosplay DND stuff and I'm like
that's how magic is and there are people
I know who genuinely thought that when I
went to the comic the card shop or the
comic shop to play cards we would dress
up like Wizards and like I cast a spell
on you when in actuality we're playing
poker dude if you could get a that is a
good idea about a card game with like
infantry you have your M1 Abrams card
tank you get weapon all the different
guns all the different mods for all the
different guns that you can equip on
your ground exactly yeah I've always
wanted that I was talking to my friends
I was like I would rather play so here's
a thing about magic the Gathering it's
chess and poker combined this is why
I've been watching a lot of Poker I love
poker but magic is just so much more fun
because like you're instead of holding
two cards
your guys holding seven cards then
you've got the board State and you're
like okay you're sitting there thinking
you're like this guy left two islands
untapped and he knows that I need to
play my finisher right now otherwise
he's gonna crush me out
but he's got those two islands if I play
this he's got a counter spell is he
bluffing or does he actually have it so
what do you do you assume he has it you
play you kind of somebody you play a
mid-range try and coax them out that way
if he does have it he counters the wrong
thing slowing you down if he doesn't
have it your mid-range can hold him off
for alternative that's that's why I like
magic but my friends would be like I
don't want to play goblins and wizards
and I'm like I get it man like and so I
had one friend out uh uh this this chick
friend of mine I was like there's a
vampire set and she was like what and I
showed her inner strad and she's like
okay that's cool she's like I don't care
about Wizards and goblins but the
vampire Victorian setting is fun she got
into it I look at it as math and
everything else is cosmetic the names
the pictures the colors all that stuff's
irrelevant essentially it's just all
about the numbers what about an
elaborate role-playing campaign that you
set up where it's just dudes at a like
at a Factory and there's nothing
exciting to see how you just roll to see
like when your lunch break
who's on who's on assembly line one two
or three the widget you made is only 73
well I mean have you seen these video
games that they've got these days like
trucker simulator and it's just you play
a game where you're in a truck and you
just drive for four hours I'm not they
made it was a car wash simulator yes
they made patrol officer simulator where
you pull people up and give them tickets
that's it yeah I can't you can't make
jokes anymore because the satire is real
it's a real thing somewhere so there's
no jokes
simulator have you guys seen duck
simulator it's a no fantastic Are You
The Gun simulator I don't know yes you
are the oh yeah yeah I've seen that it's
amazing
uh it's a goose or duck simulator Goose
um it's I don't think it's called Goose
simulator no what is that but it's the
goose game and it's really fun it's
amazing goat simulator's hilarious Goat
Simulator is fun too yes good simulator
but those are those are real games that
are silly yeah the goose game is funny
you're a goose you run around and you
honk at people and you make the kids cry
Untitled Goose game yeah oh yeah and you
steal stuff from people and that's
amazing that game is so much fun there's
a goose running around you can flap your
wings you guys ever been attacked by a
goose yeah yeah they're jerks man yeah
Surfer is asking for it though a turkey
buzzword attacked my car one time what a
dude I flew into it like flew into
indented the front you know bumper what
what happened when the goose attacked
you uh the geese are wild anyone knows
Canadian geese they are terrorists I
gotta read this is a good one
uh Russell Aaron says Tim I'm stationed
on a submarine out of Washington I miss
your show and news generally when I am
on a deterrence Patrol is there a way
that there there would be a weekly email
newsletter from timcast we're working on
it we are working on a weekly uh email
newsletter
because some people tend to become
members but we could also just create an
email list for free so that we have
emails and then here's the idea
you can sign up for the email list and
then once a week we give you like here
were the guests we had here were the
members only segments we had become a
member to watch these here's the free
news we had because we need a vehicle
for delivering news to people and it'd
be something that you you'd opt into by
signing up I would never do anything
where it's like you sign up and get
automatically put in an email list it
would be like sign up for our email list
to get a weekly update on the various
news stories guests and members only
segments and then you won't miss
anything and we've talked about it we're
actually in the process of building it
we got the team already working on it so
I'm really excited about that
all right easy Dog Log says hey Tim if
you're into end of the world scenarios
you should read or listen to the book
one second after it's about an EMP
Global attack talking about building a
toaster reminded me of the book here's
what you got to do
buy a microwave old Cheapo microwave all
right
then dig a hole
open a microwave put a laptop a phone
whatever you can fit in it close it bury
it
microwave is a faraday cage there you go
or build a faraday cage build a smaller
Faraday Box inside of it then put a
microwave inside that box then put your
stuff inside of it a lot of people talk
about oh if the solar flare comes you
know put your stuff in a faraday cage
bro Faraday cage will not protect your
stuff
the solar flare is more it's too
powerful it will Rip right through a
faraday cage you will need a multiple
layered Faraday cage to keep diminishing
it maybe even a lead box or something
but then I'll tell you this in the land
after the solar flare hits the man with
a working cell phone is King
you're going to be like I can calculate
distance and take pictures of things
imagine what it would be like to not be
able to tell someone what's going on
instantly like it used to be back in the
day like some do to get into a fight and
you'd have to run home and be like a
thing happened and tell each person
individually now you go on Twitter and
you're like dude did thing and everyone
instantly knows I feel fortunate to be
from the time before the internet
because I still think of it as weird the
internet I still see all like the how
it's different than normal life without
electricity totally all right one more
here Double R says J doing Nicholas Cage
impression
well I knew it was going to come I knew
everybody was going to say do your Nick
Cage please
I've invented my own technique of acting
it's called Nouveau shamanic and I put
bones in my pocket I don't know if it
does anything but that's what I do
there's a real clip of him saying that
oh wow that's a real thing all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member over
at timcast.com click that join us button
because we've got a big library of
members only uncensored shows going back
years it's Friday night hope you're
having a good time thank you so much for
hanging out with us we will have clips
from the shop throughout the weekend
we'll be back on Monday you can follow
the show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcastj do you want to
shout anything out yes thank you just
real quick I did want to shout out I
have a live event February 11th we'll be
performing uh me my wife BG Cumby it's
going to be funny he's a philosopher of
Comedy we have an hour of Madness and
then we have four hours of intense
lectures so it's a weird mix where is
that what is it Austin Texas February
11th you can get tickets on my Twitter
there or on the Eventbrite and what's
your Twitter
uh Jay Dyer Jay and find me right there
yeah Jay Dyer that was awesome thank you
so much for coming thanks for bringing
all the books that was definitely uh a
trip down memory lane for me
um my website is Lucan sensor.com I have
a lot of really interesting things going
on there a lot of members a lot of
conversations on our Forum three master
classes and I will be uploading one of
the members video tomorrow on rumble.com
forward slash we are change but the
members area you get it first look
uncensored.com see you there I'll Echo
the sentiment Jay thank you so much for
coming and bringing those books that was
awesome thanks for a run to the gauntlet
of questions that was incredibly
enlightening a lot of fun you guys were
great yeah and here's some more many
more that was great um I'm Ian Crossland
follow me on the internet anywhere you
want to Eddie and Crossland and serge
duprea yeah uh at surge.com uh this is
really fun I enjoyed it Jay thanks for
coming out it was great your uh your
impressions are great man thanks yeah
and uh yeah uh yeah yeah it's okay you
guys find me on Twitter uh Instagram
search calm spell it out yeah it was fun
one all right everybody thanks for
hanging out we will see you all in the
clips throughout the weekend and then
again on Monday cheers